hi everyone and welcome to the Jess
pearly things and today I might Jennifer
identifying as Pearl
and I'd like to introduce our guests and
don't forget to subscribe because it
doesn't cost anything so I'd like to
know your name
your age
your relationship status and how long
you've been in that relationship
starting with the young man yeah nice to
meet you Auntie my name is China I'm
back again I'm 38 I'm a relationship and
it's recent
hi Auntie my name is Yosef all my
handles are at yoyo Hassan I'm single
and I'm 27.
pleasure to be here Auntie my name is
Mason I'm 27. I've been single now for
about five years
nice to meet you Auntie my name is
Brittany
there's no
hi my name's Tyler also
um I'm 27 and in a relationship
have them for
not load
right for the young ladies who are in
the relationship
are you a modern woman or are you a
traditional woman in that relationship
and can you tell me
why how what makes you think now
[Music]
I think I'm modern but I still hold a
lot of Traditional Values
100 expand on that Traditional Values
so in terms of like in my relationship I
definitely cater to my man I just still
believe it can you speak into the
microphone please yeah I still believe
in like
I cook for him I clean for him and like
he comes home his slippers are at the
top of the stairs I take pride in that
still but then I'm still very much like
in a modern relationship if that makes
sense
so I do it I have a lot of traditional
venues but we're in a modern
relationship so you've told me the
Traditional Values what are the modern
values that you think you have so I
could dress how I want
I can speak to everyone I have male
friends I dance how I want I drink as
much as I want and I feel like that's
very modern because I have I have older
brothers and stuff like that and that
that stuff doesn't run for them but in
my relationship it does but then I still
have Traditional Values I cook for him I
clean for him on my days off because we
both work and stuff so when I'm not
working I'm cooking for him his pajamas
are folded on the pillow his slippers
are left at the top of the stairs but
it's still like a very modern
relationship because I will dress in
that skimpy little dress I would drink
as much tequila as I want and I'll stay
out till I want so I feel like we have a
very
um
a very good balance of modern and
traditional I think that's that's how it
works these days okay
yeah I'd kind of say the same because I
like like to I believe in the
Traditional Values like cooking and just
keeping home as a woman so I do agree
with that but at the same time I think
like you could still live your life you
could still go out and socialize that
with your friends I guess traditionally
women wouldn't really go out or like
things like girls holidays going to
Ibiza things like that I think that's
okay it happens you know as well no
nothing happens but yeah so I want a
traditional woman go to Ibiza
um it's just like I guess drinking party
holiday it's kind of like not the norm
back then I guess but now it is because
it's like that's the modern thing that's
normal
so
both of your partners would have would
let you or would be okay with you going
on ladies holidays
absent kind of
um we've spoken about this so yeah
yeah my boyfriend 100 has it happened
um yeah kind of at the beginning stages
but yeah it was kind of like but now
it's kind of like um maybe sometimes not
as much maybe why not because I've been
going a lot so obviously in the past so
what's the difference between going then
and going and you just got to consider
someone else's feelings and yeah
because I guess you've got to treat
someone how you would want them to treat
you so it's like if he was going all the
time like freelance holidays yeah I
wouldn't like it so you're losing your
modern values and gaining more
traditional ones yeah
okay young man you're in a relationship
yes what makes your young lady work for
you is she modern or is she traditional
um I think more than what Traditional
Values like what she what they said
what does she do for you how do you mean
what does she do for me they said I want
to know what she actually does for you
um she brings me peace and that's
something that I haven't found
um and the last show I was talking about
dealing with problem problematic boss
[ __ ] per se
um and I think one of the most important
things that I've I've found as I've
grown up and the women is that I just
want peace I'm a hard-working individual
um I know what I want and one of the
things I want is just peace and a fun
person someone I can do things with I'm
someone that needs to be taken out of
their comfort zone a little bit
sometimes and I think with the right
woman they're gonna make you do things
and come outside of yourself out of your
comfort zone a little bit so I think
that's what I don't need there's a lot
of things that I thought I needed before
I don't even need those things such as
um
I thought maybe I needed a woman that
was supposed to support me and from the
from the ground up and help me business
or whatever and and support me and be
there and that whole story of probably
what my parents had and what a lot a lot
of people had but I also understand that
that for a lot of women that can be hard
and you know a lot of men might want the
woman that's going to be around from
when they had nothing and to grind up
but in reality it doesn't always happen
for people so I also think that as long
as you're willing to go out and get as a
man then you might meet that person
later on and if you've got some of that
stuff as long as you can bring you peace
and some of the things that you need to
figure out that's the most important
thing for me
so having your woman going out drinking
tequila oh
wearing skimpy clothes going out with
our friends toy before will she still
fit your no why not why those are
problems for me as they were saying it I
just said on the left she was saying
that I keep my male friends I wear what
I want I go where I want
um and then the right she's saying well
I used to do some of those things but
now I've got a man I don't do that thing
and you're asking why because you
understand that your mind's not going to
be happy about that I think at some
point you have to understand that
you can't do some of the same things
that you did when you're single in your
relationship like you know and with a
lot of these modern women they want to
do they want to have the cake and eat it
so you can't be well you can because you
know a woman has the right to choose you
can choose what you want to wear and all
of that stuff but if you have a partner
you need to think about how that can how
that part how that can be perceived and
also not putting yourself in an
environment some places where it allows
you to be you know
isn't perception a personal thing though
how do you mean so you're saying how it
can be perceived if a girl wants to go
away and not have fun enjoy a holiday of
our friends and be completely loyal I
don't see the issue well it depends who
she's going on holiday with is she going
on holiday with five other girls that
are all in relationship or is she the
one person in relationship going with
four single girls now if she's going
with four single girls now it's no one
to tell what those single girls should
do on holidays so if they want to be on
a table for example and then you know
let's um some guys throw some bottles
off and ask them to go on a table those
single those four single girls don't
have to do what they want to do but the
problem lies now your girl is in this
position now so she can't be the one
asking him that actually goes I can't do
it because she's ruining the party so
now she puts herself on the table
alcohol intoxication things are
happening right now
um and then men are moving to your girl
now she's not going to have it because
she's your girl she's gonna like look
I've got a man and the rest of it but at
the same time now you put yourself your
girl in a position where you have men
that are now like so where's your man
why is your man not here if he was my
girl I wouldn't let you I'll be out here
with you right now you start to have
some of those things and you see that
saying when they say I was drunk it was
a mistake that's never happened in a
scenario when someone wasn't drunk and
it was a mistake so how do we get
ourselves out some of these scenarios by
not putting ourselves in these scenarios
but if you know how to hand yourself in
that scenario then it doesn't matter if
you're in that scenario or not and if
you know how to trust your girl then
there's nothing to do about trust I
don't trust men no listen no I agree I
agree
so okay so this is one of the things
that we need to understand in life right
like I've got I've got um Three Sisters
I spoke about them before my sisters are
married and the child I had a younger
sister that was directly under me and I
used to look after I went to like we
used to go travel to school and the rest
of it a lot of things that we we talk
about they come from a point of Love see
when your mom used to
say to you or where you're going to be
or what time you're going to be home who
are you with she didn't do that because
she didn't care if she did it because
she loved you I see there's something
that's that's been missing when men do
this we don't do this because we're
trying to stop you if your happiness
we'll do this because we generally love
you you as a woman might not see some of
the dangerous us men have seen and what
we understand so I can't treat every man
that that is going to be out there that
has been raised by by in a two in a in a
loving home he's going to treat women
like this a lot of times as you've seen
men and other people in these in these
um in in these situations they can act a
certain way so all I'm saying is I'm not
saying I don't trust her I'm not saying
that the other people you don't trust
yeah and it's the scenario so one of the
ways you can avoid this is by not
putting yourself in certain scenarios
that's all I'm saying and when you have
a partner and someone that obviously
um you consider that you love you have
to think about how they make may
consider things I get it but at the same
time then your your restriction from
what she's up exactly
where she's going normally like she's
like babe look I wanna the girls again
X1 XYZ on this on a Hindu or the girls
want to go away to XYZ are you stuck on
that yes
I think like you've got a your
girlfriend's gotta think you know what
kind of friends am I going out with
because as a girl you know how your
friends are so you know like if this if
I go with these two friends they're
gonna be like that that shows your
woman's week no no but it does no but
I'm saying like you can say you know
what I'm not gonna put myself in that
position so she should make the Judgment
for herself just all right the guy let
me jump on that when you say position
what position is she putting herself
like for example say if you go on a
girl's holiday and your friends are
there and they're single as he said and
you they invite a load of lads back and
then they're sleeping together and your
girl's just there like go to bed
it's like that sort of situation say
it's like happens like you you can't
what happened
if something happens then you're
allowing that to happen like I have a
lot of single friends I'll go on a
holiday I love my boyfriend so [ __ ]
much I'm I'm so loyal yeah but I could
still have two single friends and
they're linking up with guys but but I
would tell my boyfriend like oh these
these so and so are talking to these
guys but he knows I'm not doing anything
yeah I do the same but at the same time
they're not going to want you in that
situation of course in a room with free
guys
it's not about what situation you put
yourself in it's how you handle yourself
in the situation can I answer your
question when you go out
and your dress is a certain way and
you've got a partner who are you
representing who are you presenting
myself
you're not presenting yourself as your
Man's partner you're not representing
your man you're just going out as
you yeah yeah I'm going out with me
right so okay to the young man if you're
a woman that you've got now we're now in
skimpy clothes drank tequila went to
ibifa would you believe that she's
representing you how would you expect
because I'm look I'm listening to what
you said about perception and I'm
thinking
a hen night
in a spa with female friends having
their makeup and they're done jacuzzi
never your nails done but also champagne
how is that perceived rather than hen
night skimpy clothes tequila dancing on
tables
in Ibiza I think a lot of what is the
perception how does it look so that's
what he's saying about how it's
perceived how does it look and does he
want his woman
representing him in that way bro look
for example right like the problem of
this is is
you can do whatever you want now you can
do whatever you want but the moment you
have a partner you need you're not by
you do represent them so how many how
men look at other men is we judge them
so we don't just judge you about how
much money you have do you understand so
when you're outside and you rep I know
that's your man over there and we can
see in the nightclub how you act
reflects on him it's a reflection of how
much no it is because if you respect him
you want to do certain things if you
thought he was worthwhile you would
realize actually people know who my man
is I want to do certain things so when
you're outside in a public place you
represent your man whether or not you
like it or not whether or not you like
it or not you do you need to be specific
like grinding on another geez is a
different story but if you're just
dancing enjoying yourself a bunch of
girls wait we never you've got to be
specific you didn't say anything about
dancing
so we need to split we need to split
enjoying versus out there potentially um
disrespecting or perceptions of other
people if my girl is out I don't want
any of my friends to send me a video
saying oh why is your girl on This
Girl's On this man's table that in
itself enough that one above me it won't
bother you like sugar insecure one bit
listen this is this is why I see Life
yeah if you've got a goal and you trust
her and she trusts you and you've got a
love and relationship if she's gonna
cheat she's going to cheat
when did he mention
he keeps going back to this thing it has
a lot to do about cheating why did you
cash it on a man's thing because my
girlfriend my potential wife should not
be on another table another man's you
that's in security
I'm trying to let him say what you're
saying because I think he's means it's a
sense of respect that you guys are you
have to understand something this is the
modern thinking you want to have a man
you want to have all the benefits of a
man a loyal guy that's not do you want
your man out there sleeping over women
I'm asking a question but why is that
I'm not I didn't say you was I'm asking
you a question okay so okay us as men
and women we look at loyalty different
things by what you're doing that is
actually disloyal and if you can't see
it it's because you're not a man and I'm
trying to try would you do that to your
man what what I'm saying knowing that
you got a man now you're gonna actively
go out there saying I want to wear what
I want I'm gonna go out who I want I'm
gonna do all these things doesn't matter
what my man thinks because that's the
case then just no I would wear what I
want because I feel like I don't really
you wearing clothes I think that's a
that's you and yours that's your
expression of self expression of
insecurity but at the end of the day I
think in general you would think of your
man in certain situations so so when you
so so when you so so when you went out
to Canada for example in it yeah so
you're gonna tell me you're gonna wear a
little boy you're gonna wear a little
thong and booty stuff out if I wanted to
but that's not how I guess I didn't
that's choice but why would your
boyfriend want to have a an issue with
that if if you are a loyal girlfriend
why could he not look at you and think
that's my girlfriend no one else is
[ __ ] touching her that is the moment
you wear that you put yourself in a
scenario where men are actually going to
touch you but why but hang on
we're talking about particular garments
so I'm gonna create scenarios you're
moving the goal post you can dance where
you want you can go where you want you
can do what you want
anything you could say you could say Oh
by putting that watching you're putting
in a scenario where you could get wrong
of course you are what hold on hold on
hold on a second hold on a second hold
on a second there has to be hold on I've
got a diamond chain on my neck it's
worth a lot of money yeah yeah if I
decide to go walk around in the middle
of the night in some Hood place and I
get robbed yeah yeah who is gonna feel
sorry for me if I had it swinging around
my neck end of the day I know what I'm
doing so he puts myself on a scenario I
should be able to go anywhere in the
world and wear what I want but we don't
right so if I've got a daughter and my
sister I'm gonna teach them to say babes
you should be able to wear what you want
do what you want to go what you want but
we live in a world where there's some
evil people around there's some demons
right this is how you teach your kids
you don't teach them that everything in
the world should be fine everything
should be okay you teach them the
dangers and potential what can happen
what you guys do is you guys say you
know what nothing matters in life we go
out there when something bad happens
then you want to scream where is me I'm
saying actually look looking from a
different perspective we should be doing
things we should be mitigating scenarios
on things that can potentially happen
that's all I'm saying I have three
sisters bro no you're right
so if you've got seven nieces would you
say to your niece you know what you know
what um where go on the Titus um a
little little Skirt walk in the middle
of of happening but I just say you need
to be you need to be careful
okay okay so when there's a caveat you
said we don't care what she wears no but
you did it again you said wear what you
want but be careful of your surroundings
so there is a caveat if you have this if
you have this so they don't care if
she's I don't care if she's gonna London
Kent or women no guys he is right on
what he says how men think because I
went to Carnival for example and then
these guys were coming up trying to talk
to me and I said oh sorry I've got a man
and then they were like well where's
your man wait
you're saying classy yeah not once did
she mentioned classic there's a
difference between classy and skimpy who
said skimpy he wouldn't have a problem
with his woman looking at Classy yeah
okay
that's why Art's a perception so you
can't now turn around and say classy
nobody's complaining about it
what I'm saying is here they're talking
about it doesn't what they're trying to
say is about perception about it doesn't
matter where you are some men are going
to try and move to you I don't care what
scenario we're in I don't care if you're
in a five-star higher class private
event and you're dressed from head to
toe in some lovely garment some man is
going to try and move to but it's how
they move to you
it matters
how you conduct yourself and who you are
with actually hang in a minute excuse me
young lady I'm terrible with names so
forgive me why did you stop
when you said that how you used to be
compared to now that you've stopped
certain things why did you stop the
reason I stopped because I realized I
don't like certain I wouldn't like
certain things so I just then had to
just look at the bigger picture like if
I wouldn't want him doing that and then
I wouldn't do it myself did he tell you
to stop no did he ask you to no if he
did then I probably wouldn't have right
yeah so you've done it because you
wanted to do it just consider it when
you're in a relationship things are
different so what make what made it
different just because I mean if you
went out and you were wearing no I know
you said you don't know I know you said
it you don't wear skimpy clothes I know
you said that but the people you move
with the things that you do the places
that you go to I only have a few friends
so I still like I'm with the same
friends but I just mean like in terms of
if I didn't have a man then I could be
out all the time all the time all the
time but obviously now I'm in a
relationship I'm more with him so I'm
not like outside you know what I mean
how do you feel in yourself I feel good
are you missing out no do you feel more
secure yeah I'm fine how's your lunch
with your man now you just now you don't
go out so much that's good and I'm
obviously saving money so
is it better yeah so what do you prefer
night scene with your man or night set
with the girls
I didn't say that she can't do both I
said which one does she prefer because
too much energy to go out so it's not
whether it's all my man or my girls I
love my girls yeah but at the end of the
day it's just a lot of energy for me to
be going out and doing all this and I'd
just rather stay in everything
everything is not our personal
preference
I'm not like oh my God I'm not allowed
to go I'll still go out but I'm just
more like yeah I get it yeah so the
young men there your relationship status
single 3.5 years why uh prefer single
why uh because I'm too selfish with my
time it would it wouldn't be fair to
commit to someone else with how busy and
selfish I am with my time exactly so
you're basically saying so you've been
have you been celibate for three years
no no so you've just been single yeah
just single so are you choosing modern
women then uh I'm choosing women that I
can have a Vibe with I can have a
connection with on a temporary basis
I'm a complete against the fuckboy
culture so the football culture is you
tell a girl
um I like you I want to get with you uh
I see a future of us I'm against all
that [ __ ] if you that's not what you
want if that's not what you want and
you're telling the go to that to get
into that bet you're a [ __ ] boy you're a
dick I tell girls how it is I say look
listen I'm single I'm very selfish of my
time I don't want a relationship I think
you're attractive we get we get on well
where it goes where it goes if you're
happy to be involved with me whilst
doing that that's right that's up to you
if you're not then that's up to you as
well but if that person then wants to
engage with me after me telling them the
fact that I don't want a relationship
that I'm happy being on my own and they
still engaging me and we have I don't
know whatever happens then what's the
issue in it was you ever want a
relationship eventually yes but not
marriage and what kind of relationship
would you describe your woman and your
relationship how you'd like it I want to
uh I do want a wife without the the
marriage contracts involved I don't I
don't believe nothing is old-fashioned
library on that yeah
um I just don't I think marriage was
created a very long time ago to inherit
wealth and to secure
uh I don't know the 100 facts on it but
I'd like to secure
partnership between two people
are your parents married my parents
married 46 years yeah are they still
married still married to this day man so
I'm not basing it on childhood trauma
where the hell did you get this from bro
bro listen is
I I fully don't believe in monogamy I
don't believe in it I said it's out loud
on the internet right now I don't
believe in monogamy I do believe in
monogamy it um exists in in nature
amongst like animals like
um uh love birds love birds swans
Penguins monogamy does exist monogamy
does exist but I don't believe Hume I do
not believe humans are monogamous
animals however we are so intelligent as
a species I believe you can choose if
you want if you love someone enough and
you respect their values that that
person would be highly offended if you
slept with another person because you
love them then you should respect that
value and then you wouldn't sleep with
another person however I don't actually
believe we're meant to be monogamous
what you do in your personal life
because you're an intelligent human
being and that person would be
disrespected if you slept with another
individual you should respect that and
not do it however I don't I think it
goes against our DNA but if you are a
person that respects your partner and
they say I would not a happy be happy if
you sleep with another person then you
should do so you should respect their
values if you don't respect the values
you should not be with that person so
you would be okay with the person that
you're seeing or like your girlfriend
because you want one eventually
he hasn't described his perfect
relationship
my per relationship my relationship is
when I am mentally in a place where I
feel I can take on someone else I don't
believe I'm in a place right now where I
can have someone in my life because it
wouldn't be fair to them because I
wouldn't be able to commit to them not
commit to them as in sexually or
emotionally commit to them with my time
I believe if you have a relationship
with someone you need to be fully
entwined with that person uh give them
time nurture that relationship I don't
have time to do that so it'd be unfair
to devote myself to an individual when I
don't have time in my life have you got
any non-negotiables for your uh yeah but
she has a boyfriend
I'm joking
why do I feel like I should be asking
like do best friends or you know can
male friends be friends with females
but we're friends
we're a group of female and male friends
so let's not go there let me tell you
let me tell you how I know I was told
that men and women can't be friends
no is there a possibility like if you're
good friends of a man that one day he
might think you know what I will sleep
with her does she ever think you know
what I think if I was single then we'll
sleep with her why I'm just asking a
question what is that why does everyone
put sex on a pedestal like why is that
why is that all right listen to this
because sex is important because men
have to in order okay listen in order
for me and you have to sex we have to
have some value in US here if you in
order for me me and you to go out there
and get sexual no no no
in order for me and you to go out there
and find women to have sex with yeah
caveat um we need to have some value to
us so for example if you go and sleep
with 10 supermodels and I look at you I
already know this guy's got something I
know you got money I know you got status
I know you're something you got it's
more than just games this guy's got
something right yeah in order for them
to sleep with um 10 guys I don't need
nothing offer to do just open the speed
yeah they've got to be there if you go
on your Instagram now and you write oh
yeah you know what I'm feeling horny
today for 365 days you can find one man
out of your Instagram that's Gonna Wanna
that's gonna want it if I go and do that
someone's gonna work you go what what
people gotta say about you people want
to start putting Instagram and getting
my [ __ ] flagged you know what I mean
they're gonna be like what's wrong with
this guy and this is the thing right the
only reason men and women men and women
cannot be friends the only reason we can
be is because one person has put the
other person in the friend zone I
disagree with it let me explain it to
you explain explain because I just don't
understand okay so let me explain it to
you let me explain it to you by default
yeah who in the Friendship then because
you are her male friend so explain to me
now did you put him in the Friendship
group or did you
we'll automatically have done that
because that hasn't come to it but if
you really want to test it now yeah you
just went against your values
explain who's let him speak it's
different no no no no no no no no no no
but you know what I know her family and
her brother but if you want to do that
because she I look as my sister so it's
not really that well because I actually
know I found him but if you want to do
that this is what's happened right she's
in my friend zone because I look as my
sister I'm in her friend zone because
she looks at me as her brother but the
but the only one way to test it out is
if she one day approaches me and says
you know what did it and that's the way
we're gonna find out and that's the real
win and I'll be honest with you not with
her because it goes deep it's to me
that's instant but it was another girl
then hell yeah and this is and wait hold
on a second we spoke earlier on and we
said this right you two you two are
friends right you two are friends right
we're all friends us don't even
if for any reason and be honest don't
cap because we're live to hate the
cappers if she messaged you and said
look I've broken up with my man I'm
feeling really lonely would you just
come round and if she doesn't oh she put
anything over then just come and keep me
company just come and stay the night in
the bedroom would you do it I said nah
bro
just ask the question bro
wait wait wait it's not a simple
question
that's not that's based on a
relationship you have that individual
I've got many attractive single friends
who are females doesn't mean I'm gonna
stop it's a relation you go no if I said
with you that'd be weird
okay
that's my mate if we slept then our
friendship is weird
we don't like each other we don't like
each other to the point of I could see
myself in a relationship would you sleep
with him and you have your sex and
that's your relationship had a window I
know they're both my friends I can look
at them I'm not stupid I can see girls
fancy them they're not ugly guys but do
I want to sleep with them I'm not asking
I'm not asking you I'm not I'm not
asking you I'm asking them I'm asking
this about Brits and attracts have gone
I'm not an idiot oh my God
that's it and the story in it so so if
she if she tried out of all the millions
of attractive women out there why have
we got no no no no no no see what we're
doing is what we're doing we're going
around
and as men
straight A man is asking you something
straight yes or no see attractive girl
if she put it on you and said I want to
sleep with you she has no man she's
single I've known you for 10 years you
know what you know what I've been
looking past a guy that was always for
me I just want you tonight oh you know
what just make me feel good tonight you
know what are you gonna tell them no are
you gonna push off are you gonna say oh
my God you're my sister just be honest
get off me okay cool you said no you say
no okay cool
back to your five non-negotiables for
your perfect partner when you decide to
get a relationship uh
what's the word maternal maternal
um
uh caring of course attractive
as good uh humor
is that for yep
um
intelligent so have you ever had any of
those five in any of your female
Associates that you've passed along the
way in your single them I've never got
close enough to find out
so when are you going to decide to get
close enough when I'm ready
and about what age would you be now I'm
talking about the age of the woman uh
younger than me
how old are you now I'm 27. I don't plan
listen I don't actually
I don't I we know when people say age is
just a number I fully fully believe that
like age is just a number of people die
at different ages all the time your age
doesn't specify how old you are
technically obviously it's a way of
measuring it but people age different
rates all the time due to how you live
how your lifestyle is what kind of
person you are genetics everything so
I don't put an age on when I'm going to
settle down I put an age on I put a date
on it when I'm I'm ready mentally I
don't believe Oh by by the age of 30
I've got to do X Y and Z it's when I'm
ready I'll do X Y and Z so how do you
feel about body counting women high body
caps
[Music]
um because I'm just saying that you're
helping rack it up yeah
these are the guys you need to watch out
for these are the ones
out there racking it up
you're trying to put a blame on us I'm
just going I'm just going by I'll get it
yeah
we had a similar conversation earlier
and it when it comes to this sort of
thing what we've got to understand is
women choose and pick and choose who
they sleep with right men will sleep
with who they can right a woman just has
to be there a woman can go out and get
to sleep with whoever she wants she can
go out to a club to a bar to a pub she
can pull like that all day a man has to
work yeah
I'm tired of hearing the men out there
saying I want a woman with a low body
count and then they're helping to Rack
it up and then they're saying oh no it's
the women because the women they're The
Gatekeepers and they're this and they're
that's true they are but at the end of
the day
he's had a lot of Gatekeepers when is he
gonna lock down the gate I would just
like to know how how does he feel about
a woman with a high body count sorry
just before your Arts can I just say
something so this is what I'll say in
the last show on it I was saying like
like these are the men that leave the
woman with a trauma no no no no no no no
no no no no
way wait wait wait wait wait no problem
listen no no no no no wait let me finish
this you think I'm talking about like
you're gonna actually mentally destroy
it I'm not talking about that bro but
when she has you they talk about Alpha
Widow when she gets to a certain level
of man and she has this man and then you
drop her bro after that no other man
matches can I just say something right
yeah advocate
any woman that suffers trauma after him
deserves it because as he says like he's
going out there he's telling them thank
you exactly
I do not want a relationship so as far
as I'm concerned if like how they say
catch feelings for him that is a problem
he's out there and he spoke out he's not
hiding it he's out there backing up
Miley
no
the guy said if the guys
and you haven't let him answer yet and
I'd like him to answer how do I feel I
think um it comes down to listen the
girl wants to wrap up numbers that's up
to hers her body her choice I don't I
don't give up no I'm not talking about
if a woman I'm talking about you said
that eventually you'd like to settle
down I'm talking about what is the
highest body count that you would accept
for your future
don't ask the question no no last
question I don't care answer numbers are
subjective so if someone could think 10
is high someone could think a hundred
times this is all subjective but I
depends on the person listen I would
like a number a number what do you want
I would like single digits single digits
single digits okay so can I have you
ever I know that not a lot of people
talk about body count I'll talk about
the women that you associate with yeah
have you spoken to them about body count
uh it crops Up Normally it crops up
they're masking me I'll reverse the
question on them have any of them been
double digits all of them have been
double digits okay actually no no not
all of them no no it's given some of
their Jews some of them have been oh
you've been the double digit number 10.
I've put them over the edge yeah yeah
but uh no most I I never actively ask a
girl oh how how many guys you slept with
whatever I've never ever asked that
question however some goals will go to
me oh I bet you slept with loads of
girls and I'm like I just I don't ever
answer the question and then I'll go
well how many boys use that with no tell
me and they're asking me how many I've
said I've just gone you so when you
decide to settle down yeah will you ask
her what happened but it'll be that
question will be somehow incorporated
into a load of questions in the stage of
talking it won't be something I asked
six months in oh that will def that that
will be a building block to me depending
where I go further this person yeah so
it does matter to you then of course of
course it matters you said single digits
of course of course nine is the time
listen if you said to me right now you
said if you said to me me and you just
meet at a bar and with no flirtation
between us we're just talking you said
to me randomly a conversation come up
you said I'll set with 50 guys I would
not judge you one bit
no but let's not bro
I've just met the guy no no no no so I'm
just asking you but she's made she met
with 50 bodies yeah it's no way that but
just honestly like it's not singing
religious bro of course he said he
wouldn't Because unless they're on the
flip side let's say on the flip side
it's been four months you've been seeing
some girls she's really nice she's
attract I wouldn't let it get four
months
no no no no hit me out okay let's say
three months you've been seeing her
she's attract active your family love
her she's beautiful loads of guys think
yo have you got this girl and then you
ask her how many bodies have you catch
and she says double digits are you gonna
nope sorry I'm just gonna I don't
believe you would I'm gonna put in the
bin now my mom loves you how old is she
she's 30.80
let's just put it in that perspective
it's been three months you've been
seeing this girl she's beautiful your
friends think yo how have you got this
girl she's absolutely stunning she's
career driven she's ambitious she's
everything that you value in a girl but
then she likes to say do you know what
yo like I've I've it's double digits
I've slept with 20 people are you then
gonna say
I'm doing it
or play a part are you then gonna say to
her you could be the love of my life but
sorry you've slept with 20 Men explain
are you gonna do that yeah it's a great
scenario it's a great scenario I respect
what you're saying but Joseph would not
let it get to three months for asking
that question and the love of my life
could never slack if he was listening to
what he's saying he actually said that
that would be part of his vetting
process yeah so I suppose that you go
for that before I wouldn't say it again
so although you said you don't judge
women but you do he's not judging
that's fine that's fine but just but
China you didn't say that but he said oh
I wouldn't judge you I said he does
wouldn't judge you as a person I judge
you as being my partner for the rest of
the morning I think the problem is this
what happened last time right
um and this is what I think I was
getting a bit of backlash on social
media from a few people but it's like
men having a standard is not judging you
so you can do whatever you want you can
win so let me just reiterate you right
this is what I believe I believe a woman
has the right to wear what she wants Uma
has the right to go where she wants she
can sleep with who she wants
consensually a woman has a autonomy a
sovereignty over her body but along with
those rights a man has rights too and I
have rights that I don't have to accept
a woman that's taking that and this is
where the people start to get upset oh
but but but because I personally don't
want to take a woman that believes
sleeping with 20 men is good for her
like I I look at her
um I look at her how she makes decisions
her decision making and I don't
personally think that's that's something
that that I want and when you say that
that's when you people get mad and the
reason people get mad is because you've
been told you can go out and do whatever
you want and sleep wherever you want and
be with everyone of course you can but
it doesn't mean that you have access to
whoever you want and that's why people
get upset so by him saying that oh yeah
um she can sleep with 50 man that's fine
but I don't want her that's a preference
he's not he's not judging her no if he
says that's the perfect example because
bucks they were so quick to jump on him
yeah but
what they didn't realize is that he's
out there wrecking that mileage
right bodies mileage whatever you want
to call it and the women don't care
he don't care because it's mutual yeah
but when he comes to want to wive
someone and he don't want it it's a
problem to the women you're saying I'm
polluting the environment
the people allowing you to pollute your
environment go for it because I'm
concerned I have no problem with you
like she said girls don't care I have no
problem with you doing whatever you want
to do because like you said you're being
honest about it I also have no problem
with you deciding that when you come to
settle down that you want somebody with
a low body count you know what I have a
problem with is all the modern women out
there that are sleeping with men like
you and they can't accept that men like
you want a woman with a low body count
Auntie that's what I always say like you
look perfect you know your buff your
tent you're young you're handsome you're
driven and any woman will have you but
what they don't understand is that you
don't want any woman [ __ ] you want a
woman for today you don't want a woman
for forever and you're gonna get lots of
women for today and they will wonder why
don't they want me forever because
you've got a high body count
because this is the way you are yeah
because I don't suppose that when you
decide to get your partner would you
feel great about her going out in skimpy
clothes and drinking tequila and dancing
on tables and you wouldn't you have a
problem with that
listen listen this is my view I said
this earlier I do listen if I trust her
and she trusts me there's a mutual trust
between us I do not if she's going to
cheat she's going to cheat we're not
talking about we're not cheating
let me say this she's going to the table
with her friends and there's another
giza's table I don't care yeah why does
the kid
don't care where you go I don't care who
you're with as long as you're not loving
other geez that's like um twerking on
another I was about to ask you who's
twerking okay
no no
no no no no
I've got Spanish stuff in a minute what
if it's not sexual weirdest it's just a
vibe
so what if she decides you know what I'm
not gonna go Carnival um I'm just gonna
go
salsa dancing regular listen you can go
Carnival just start the ground in your
battleship you can anywhere you go if
you've got a boyfriend you can do what
you want as long as you're [ __ ]
respectful I could go to the carnival
there could be people around me as long
as you're you're doing your own thing
and you're not being I think that's for
your man why can't you I think what
you're what you're not understanding
is your idea of respect in your man
my idea of respecting Your Man
his idea of respecting your man because
when you go out you're representing
yourself that's subjective myself you're
representing yourself because you said
that you go out and he knows that you're
trustworthy you can go out and you can
enjoy yourself your man hasn't got a
problem with it because he's stable with
you you're stable with him that works
for you yeah but
the way he's saying it is that
his woman represents him I'm going to be
honest when he goes out yeah
so are you saying then so let's say you
have a beautiful girlfriend you've been
together for four years you've got okay
let's say this girlfriend you've been
together four years you trust her she's
never given you a reason to ever think
that she'd be doing anything
disrespectful but babe I'm gonna go
Carnival she's dancing she's having a
good time are you gonna think okay what
is she doing why is she dancing no she's
dancing over man what is she doing she
can't go to Carnival or are you going to
think like my girl's at carnival but I
trust her you go with her I'm gonna go
with her because I did go Carnival yeah
but why have you ever been kind of
excuse me but have you ever been
Carnival with older man not with my man
have you ever been you've never been
kind of with your man but why do you
know what you need to go with me what
you need to do is to try having next
time this Carnival have it as like a
date day with your man and you will see
the difference I can understand where I
can understand where he's coming from
because
it's more sexual it's more enjoyable
listen to what I'm saying
go in with your man is more sexual that
is what I said go in as a partner I'm
sure there's lots of people out there
that have been carnival on their own
I've been Carnival I've been in the
floats at the back of the throats I've
been I've been with the with this yes
yes I'm a good sound system I don't like
I've done the with salsa band in London
Adam of another band in Barbados I've
been with I've been in carnival and the
safest place for a single woman to go on
Carnival is in the actual band buy a
costume wear a skin beauty like and buy
a costume other than that if I was going
to go Carnival I'd go with my man I'd
wear skimpy outfit as possible I would
go with my man and me and my man but if
you had to go Carnival with your woman
how would it be for you not even that
let me tell you how it was for me so let
me tell you about Carnival right because
I did Carnival right so so
see when you go Carnival
um you can walk with your girl by your
side or if she could walk a little bit
ahead of you you don't have to you don't
have to walk her hand in hand we don't
do that stuff and it'll be certain times
when you do you know because you have to
yeah because you have to keep you have
to keep together but more times she's
going to be next to your head of you put
your girl two steps ahead of you and see
what happens it's crazy and the only
reason she feels comfortable walking two
steps ahead is because I'm just there I
I didn't realize what it's like for for
a girl to go Khan is actually mad and
then when I'm walking through with the
sweet one and then people see you women
respect you more because oh because
they're out there single they're single
ass will know man getting drawn by men
they don't want to chat to but they have
to deal with it and then men are out
there being hungry trying to chat to go
and you're just there with your girl
catching your one man in your damn
business everyone's seeing you and
they're waiting you know why they're
rating you because they're seeing you
you guys together and there'll be
certain times when your girl's gonna
grab your hands you don't ask to do it
she just grabs it and at that point what
she's saying to you I want you to walk
with me then she'll drop it again and
this is what I'm trying to say to you
like
um go into Carnival you can go by
yourself but but you should go with your
man you know why because that's a whole
next experience that you're about to go
and create and sometimes when you're in
these places these are types of places
where you want to be together you know
what I'm trying to say to you um so
we're not saying you can't go no one's
saying that you can go wherever you want
but there's certain places that you
could certain things are more likely to
happen if Matt had to grab you up on one
it is Carnival I see I see videos on
Tick Tock people getting mad I tried to
chapter one this is Carnival this is
what people do this is one event we're
basically yeah we were just talking
about we were just we were just talking
about one thing what you're just talking
about so this I've I've never
experienced this this is obviously I've
never been Carnival so I can't speak on
it but I've never experienced this in
I've been to Raves festivals I've been
lad holidays all around the world I've
never experienced what you're saying
I've seen Tick Tock cine tick tocks yeah
I've seen how Barbie is now you need to
come outside
I've seen all of you like it's packed
together like sardines you're like I've
seen it I've seen how busy it is but
you're you're you are basing a whole
like a relationship an interaction or a
relationship based on one no we were
just
what he's saying is that
don't knock it till you tried it this
way
experience is different are you saying
then so if you had a girlfriend let's
say for example you couldn't go to
Carnival she wanted to go to Connie are
you saying to her you're not going no no
no no no no no no no I'm not saying
she goes there guys listen I already I
already know
no they might try to move things no
they're not going to try they're not
going to try she's gonna get about 100
man are you saying to her
no I'm not saying that I'm never saying
nothing the only time I'll ever say
something like that is if I generally
believe there's a danger my wish is
being said and when I say that you
should listen to me because I never say
that surely anywhere she goes no no no
no no no no no no no no no no let's not
do that because what you're doing it's
on a mascara because what you're doing
what you're doing you're comparing going
to the corner shop in your local area to
being out in the corner place
not just Carly but any event she can go
to yeah you'll miss any event any house
event any client Club she's gonna get
hit on see it's not that there's
different levels of risk and what you
guys are doing you guys are seeing in
every level of risk is the same and it's
not like that so what we need to do
you've not been in every single
environment nobody but he's been in
carnivals
now first of all actually festivals
totally different times
festivals and it's totally different
people essentially what you're talking
about they don't always right one at a
time what you're talking about the basis
here correct me if I'm wrong here is
you're talking about the trust you have
for an individual when they're at an
event
safety hang on right so when us when we
start going to events in like 2014 2015
it was full of love good people Good
Vibes and as the years have gone on
events have changed like we are first of
all that has massively changed now to
start attracting the wrong people yeah
past eventually started going too wrong
with people started turning up wrong
crowd started turning up the virus
started changing back in 2014 15 16 17
it was just Good Vibes no trouble no
fights no nothing as the years have gone
on different people different crowds
have started coming here so I don't care
now even going at the clubs that we know
and have been to for years and years and
years and years different people there's
different crowds there's different
people there so of course I'm always
concerned for my girls safety about
where she's going what club she's going
I don't give I don't care if we're going
okay
okay okay
but if I'm if I'm not there I'll make
sure I'll try and know people who are
there who can keep an eye out
holding it I just cut him down
you just said exactly what I said yeah
you used to go out to this place it used
to be all love Good Vibes now things
have changed now your girl wants to go
to this place that you used to go that
was all like that's all changed now it's
changed last time people got stabbed
last time a girl got sent and she wants
to go yeah and
this is what I'm saying at this point
I'm going to say actually you know what
babe I don't want you to go here now the
reason I don't want you to go has
nothing to be nothing to do other than
the fact that I know someone got stabbed
there it's changed how it used to be
it's not good vibes yeah yeah now
am I wrong for saying that no not at all
bro so then you agree with me what I'm
trying to say is that in this in today's
day and age as well I don't care where
you go
you've got to have your wits about you
no but if you love your girl yeah why
would you put up I'm not going to stop
it obviously listen listen he never said
he's gonna I'm not gonna stop her I
can't stop nobody physically what's your
point let me I know his point is he's
right no he's right but if you say
you're saying you don't care about your
bird but you care about other people but
if you have that opinion you could when
does this stop what I'm saying anywhere
so even about that it's like saying it's
a one in four thousand one of the worst
ways to travel is by car you can die get
in the Cars one or four thousand shots
one in four thousand chance you can die
in a car accident yeah right because
other people not because you're driving
because of other people yeah so what
does that mean you don't drive anymore
okay but we're not okay so if you put
someone in the car
who is completely sober but you put them
on someone that's completely drunk yeah
that's driving the complete opposite way
now this is what you're doing so you're
safe but you're putting someone in an
unsafe way in the car no no no no no no
no no no no no no no you don't no no no
no no
if they're drunk then you say to them if
you go there that person that person's
drunk and I refer you not to go and the
choice is there and then if they're
getting that car everyone in the car
sober okay but there's a car coming
towards you and there's all no but
listen listen listen we'll use your
analogy right you can't control we have
a cause we use analogy the person's
about to get in the car yeah and they've
got to get Nicole some of that strong
they know the person's drunk and maybe
the other people will knock away hold on
a second argument no because you're
trying to say if you're trying to use
the car example so I would say they use
it in a fair example because I'm saying
what you're not in control of other
drivers yeah the people in the car
you're in control with I don't want you
to drive Mason you're drunk don't drive
what I'm saying is we're all sober we're
in a car there's a car coming towards
you on a moment
the drunk driver represents
G right if you're a safe enough driver
and you're prepared enough you should be
able to avoid that job
so as far as I'm concerned
because you're in a Country Lane
as far as I'm concerned I get where
you're coming from because you're not in
control of other people so what you're
trying to say is changing it that if the
car's coming at you and that car's drunk
what are you supposed to do anything can
happen you can go down there right and
what he's trying to say is that if you
know
that there are dangers out there then
all he's going to do is make sure that
his woman is aware of it yeah aware but
exactly that's in every event
he's never said he's going to stop her
from going where she's going all he's
going to say is that the decisions that
she makes of where she's going the
decision that she makes or where she's
going he's going to let her be aware
of what's going on of course and also
another thing that fees go into Carnival
if I'm going to Carnival if I'm a man
and I'm going to Carnival with girls I'm
gonna I'm gonna dress totally different
to Carnival or somewhere like that I'm
gonna make sure number one I could wear
shoes that I can run in okay right okay
I ask my titties there's nothing hanging
out yeah yeah you know and that
got nothing that anybody can grab hold
of I got like stuff in my pockets a bum
bag or whatever and that's there's a
difference in how you go out to be safe
to be safer you can't stop nothing from
happening yeah but you can give yourself
a damn good chance to prevent it
happening so if you're going out there
and you're this is how I go and watch
Carnival I will go and I'll stand up and
I would just watch Carnival it'll go
past me yeah
but if I went out there
and I was standing up
and I had on skimpy a bikini yeah that's
what you're saying there is no way I
expect people just to walk past me it
ain't gonna happen not in carnivals of
course it ain't gonna happen in carnival
it can happen anywhere well what can I
say aren't it that ain't gonna happen
anywhere and so now coming back to you
what is your relationship state
on the same show I've been single for
quite a time now same as Joe okay how
long you've been single a few years now
how many two three not probably like
four or five yeah entanglements in
between that but single for the most
part
the Jada smithline
why have you been seeing
um I don't know life's just been real
busy so uh similar to Yo it'd probably
be unfair for me to be able to say I'll
be able to dedicate my time and myself
to one individual when I'm trying to
sort myself out first I think you're
selfish if you don't sort yourself out
first before allowing someone else to
get that close to you facts so having
sex with someone's not getting close
yeah exactly no I'm talking about is
that so that is not close for you that's
what I'm trying to say let me speak that
is not closed for you when you say for
somebody getting close I'm just trying
to find out because you might be having
sex with moon not getting close to them
sure
so I just want to know so you're having
and what's an entanglement
ask Jada Smith
explain entanglement an entanglement I
suppose you could call it caught in you
could call it dating like it's just cool
and you don't have sex when you call so
get it right well that's all right maybe
in today's news
are changing up caught in and dating if
you're gonna say caught in with sex they
call him all right I'll refresh say
dating with sex and caught in with sex
cost you more money than dating with sex
what is it I've never heard of course
before when you're calling you put out
money dating you don't dating you smash
court and you have to say it never
happens
there is a big difference
are you dating with sex yeah we could
say that auntie and so where do you get
entangled because I heard here I didn't
hear about his entanglement he was just
like Yep this is what they want I
suppose but you're getting it okay you
get into a particular scenario you think
potentially this could be someone who
you could be in a relationship with and
you couldn't end up being something
further with and as time goes on and you
get to know that individual and a bit
more that you begin to realize that
actually we haven't got as much in
common as we might think and therefore
it begins to fade a little bit and he's
like hang on a second maybe this is not
what I thought it was at the initial
beginning so therefore it begins to fade
right so do you prefer traditional women
to Modern women
that's a tough question mixture yeah or
if you deserve don't even interrupt yeah
I know his answer what I want to know is
like which one and why or do you know
what right when it comes to dating and
when it comes to entanglements
[Music]
um I suppose it's a different very
different modern view on it but when it
comes to actually someone who you want
to then actually invest time into and
begin taking more on a serious basis
you'd like to see someone who's got more
old-school morals about them and more
old-school ways about them so I've got
them built into me
um without a shadow of a doubt but I
would only give us I would only give
access to that to someone who I think is
actually worth that and it's actually
worth that time and worth that side of
me describe what you've got built in you
I don't say my old school ways and
morals what are they
[Laughter]
but I'll still like if I feel as though
someone's worth that sort of time and
investment then yeah absolutely like but
investment is in that and you do become
you know the old school gentleman ways
where you will take some of that
property you will take them out to
proper dates and proper restaurants and
get to know that individual on a far
more personal basis and open up to him a
little bit more but you only
let that side out to someone who you
think is potentially worth that and
they've got them sort of same morals and
that about them you know the types of
girls that aren't about that life and
that are just there to have a good time
and that's cool you understand that
together and you're like cool this is
what it is and that's it that's all it's
gonna be but when it's someone that you
feel as though has further potential who
could be a potential partner of yourself
and you begin to allow access to
different parts of you that you don't
give to everybody else yeah so is that
what you're looking for potentially you
do want to settle down
um good question it's not a case of me
looking to want to settle down but if
someone you don't ever go look you don't
go looking for love you don't go looking
forward like looking no no is that what
you want is that oh my god listen I met
a lot of women in my life and if someone
was to suddenly show that potential of
someone that has those old-school models
and old school ways about them and and
then yeah absolutely cool is that with
that that
there's an old school sign of um a woman
can never change a man but a man changed
changes for a woman and that's that's
100 true if you meet a woman who's got
their morals and and brings that side
out of you yeah that man will change it
doesn't matter what his past is about
that man will change for that woman to
be like you know what you are the person
and you are the woman who wants to make
me change that view and the way I've
been playing about for X Y and Z amount
of time yeah without a doubt so you do a
lot of traditional seconds
oh wow go and sell yourself a good
question
um I think what yo said maternal is 100
thing I can't wait to have a family I
can't wait to have children I've grown
up around children I've got seven nieces
I've been an uncle since I was seven
years old but three older brother's like
I can't wait to have my own children and
please God for Mama after God's ears the
woman who I decided to have children
with is a woman I spend the rest of my
life with amen actually
like making sure that that doesn't
happen that you don't have any children
oh you got me you got me you got me I
just don't ask him are you keeping it
covered
please
yeah of course yeah we try not to muck
about too much in that business yeah we
try to make sure no no no no no no no no
Auntie Jenny no Auntie Jenner so from
today on right never we play something
right every this man doesn't keep it
covered don't sleep with him
if he hasn't got his well he's gone
don't jump down and sleep with him yeah
no maternal intelligent like she needs
to be driven ambitious like she needs to
be independent
um well I love hearing about women today
like they want to be independent want to
stand on their own two feet I don't want
to rely on a man a man should look after
a woman and keep her safe in that
content type similar to what we're
talking about right like when she goes
out of a guy that's like oh I'll let my
girl go to the bar and buy a drink which
I mean if you want to buy a drink and
I'm I'll watch a guy try and chat her up
but I'll watch how she responds to that
yeah if he touches her in the wrong
position then I'm going to handle that
situation the way I need to right yeah
but you're there you're not there I'll
have people there if I need uh
you're just going against everything
she just needs to like I like a girl's
got a backbone she needs to be able to
stand up for herself and blood no mate
like Marquis is XYZ like if I wanted to
call him down in a shot where's your man
drop me to call him and bring him down
here because I'll bring him down if you
want if you really want me to stand on
her own two feet you need to be
independent look after yourself has her
own job as her own money be I don't
interdependent yeah not not a girl who
needs to rely on him I want him to do
this for me no mate you you own your own
money you go to work driven yeah you
want to be promoted you want to own your
own business whatever it is you I don't
care what job you do take pride in what
you do and work for yourself not oh yeah
he does this for me he does that for me
no she needs to be standing on her own
two feet like babe I've made this
decision I want us to go here yeah and
I'll go there if you I don't care like
tell me where you want to go let's go oh
who's going to lead the relationship you
or her I think I think relationship is a
partnership you're in that together it's
not a case of X Y and Z don't get it
wrong so if there's a final decision to
be made yeah it makes it the pair of you
know somebody has to make a fight if it
comes down to the house and things like
that she's like I want that I'm like
yeah you can have it that's cool
when it comes to that sort of stuff I
think again I think you sit down if you
ain't got a relationship where you can
sit down together and have an adult
conversation about look this is the
reality this is XYZ like what do you
want to do about it if she kicks out
fast and doesn't know how to handle it
she's immature and doesn't add to look
after stuff so you want to lead it's not
about necessarily leading it's about
sitting down and having a discussion
between yourselves and thinking about
who's going to make the final decision
somebody has to why does it why you come
to an agreement thank you like yeah if
you come to an agreement you say right
this is what I want this is what I want
and you just say fine and whatever okay
I'm saying that it's hard for two people
to lead of course it is so what's the
compromise babe you want that you want
that so I don't like I'm not gonna go
back again against your idea and go
against you and go I'm [ __ ] having
that and that's it or you're having that
and that's it so what's the compromise
we either come to a compromise or we
don't have it Mason the compromise is
they trust so if she makes a decision
you you trust in the decision yeah or if
you make it see trust in it so one
person has to do it there's never a
thing where 50 it can't always be you
can't come to a middle ground see this
relationship is gone no no no somebody
has lie in a family in life I want to
someone has to say okay and someone's
gonna be like I trust you in your
judgment I want to follow you sure you
cannot do this 50 you're going to be
arguing your whole life
he didn't say that he said that she
might agree sometimes and he might say
all right then your way oh sure but
someone has to leave but what he's
saying is that somebody so you can't see
it but it can be him sometimes thank you
but somebody has to know depending on
what it is depending on what it is
depending on what the situation is
potentially maybe what one's got more
experience in what maybe one's got does
more other than the other you've got if
I said to better Foods together you said
x y z and Brit knows far more about that
another good but listen babe I trust
your judgment I'll Trust whatever you
decide to go with I'm with you but you
realize that a real leader does that
anyway everybody gets the wrong idea of
course over man leading you're very
naive if you think you know everything a
man who leads were always I think he's
insecure and then he'll make it if the
woman's better at money then a man who
leads will allow the woman because she's
answered with money a lot of people seem
to think that a man needs and the
woman's gonna do this no you just to
work together she might I'm not
necessarily great with numbers she might
be like oh no girls who are accountants
yeah I mean I'm like babe you know far
more than I do I know x1z from XYZ
experience but you're better than that
than I am so listen I'm gonna trust your
judgment
so this thing about I don't know
everything about everything
so listen to this here this thing this
whole thing of trying to to not say
someone can be elite like we want to act
like if I call you a leader that
diminishes me it does not no yeah so
wait so even the fact that you don't
want to say I'm gonna lead it's like by
me saying that my woman is no how about
my woman understands me and Trust what
I'm gonna go and do and she's like
actually my guy you go and do this and
Lead this I might handle something else
but when it comes to certain decisions
you do that just like if it comes to
home decisions do you think I'm gonna do
anything I'm like hell no you're gonna
lead the whole thing here's the money
the budget I don't want to know what it
is just deal with it because she's gonna
lead in that thing just not that color
baby I won't even do that sometimes
fashion stuff yeah uh I would never try
and out for something but she gonna lead
in that you know what you're gonna look
good in this that's when I let you just
run you want a woman said Joe what I
hear about in society today people are
too Molly cuddled about stuff yeah so
they're not if you say something like if
I put an outfit on if I put a top on my
boys are like this but we've been at
that I hope we've known each other our
whole life so we're very brutally honest
but most the time it's like people were
saving just to make others happy God
babe what do you think to go yeah that
looks nice you don't like an idiot so if
I put a top on or if I put a jack on I
go babe what do you think I wanted to go
I look [ __ ] on you mate I just feel
there's nothing wrong in saying you know
what honest amazing I don't think it's
because you know what it is Mason when
you first started talking yeah and bitty
yo but we're gonna get back to you later
on but when you first started saying it
it was like you're bucking up against me
but when aren't any probes are you
actually were quite traditional you're
very you're very traditional you've
grown a lot like you're actually very
traditional and you're on the customer
saying the things that I want to say but
something stops you from saying it and I
think you're trying to be too safe and
it's fine to say you know what actually
I don't want my girl to go to certain
places if I'm not there I actually I do
understand there's certain dangers out
there and if I tell you he's coming
around to our way yeah and if I tell him
not to Gold it I'm not actually a
wedding I'm not a massages I'm not
whatever actually I love my girl because
all I can think about is when my mom and
dad used to get onto me about or who
those friends are hanging around with
what where are you why aren't you it's
because they loves me not because they
oh of course they wanted to stop me or
stop
right is that
I've been around I've been around the
world my mates I've seen a lot of [ __ ]
like I don't care if you're going to
Carney I don't care if you're going to
we are Festival I don't care if you're
going to fuse I don't care if you're
going to a boat at 338 I've been in the
most quiet pubs in the world and it's
erupted jump in and I've seen some
horrendous things so I don't care where
you're going I'll always have the back
ahead and my concern of
my girl is out there without me so I
need to know where that's what I wanted
to hear okay
that protective instincts there so if I
can't be there like I don't care if my
friend if she goes to Dubai I'll make
sure I know people in Dubai so if I need
to know where she is and what she's up
and she's in trouble
but just text me and just let me know
that something's going wrong and I'll
ring someone who knows someone who knows
someone that can that can help you out
or if you're in an area that I just
cannot get to or ring someone who knows
someone who knows someone that can get
you out of that situation so I'm never
not concerned about where she is or who
she's with I'm always got that [ __ ] on
the back of my brain but oh like that's
that's gonna be no matter where she goes
but at the same time you can't stop her
from going places
I just listen to him and now for the
young lady there um can I just add on to
that point just one one thing quick how
many times honestly be serious yeah yeah
go for it how many times have we been
out yeah yeah and we've seen a group of
girls yeah yeah yeah and we try cracking
on the bird yeah and there's always that
one who's got a boyfriend yeah boyfriend
yeah yeah and we do try our luck yeah of
course we try and graft it we put all
the little yeah yeah everything we can
of course and it always comes down got
boyfriend yeah and then one of the other
boys will try if they get the same
outcome yeah that's it that's what I
want mother to be like yeah okay okay
okay
you see my group of friends
we we've got the chat we've got the chat
Auntie if you're gonna say that okay
cool but are you also going to say about
the time when she did have the boyfriend
and you still got through
oh that's that oh listen that's the girl
that's the girl okay
wait no not right is that the girl or
was that you no bro that's the girl no
wait a minute to go wait a minute to go
wait a minute if you don't believe it's
the girl that means you don't believe it
no no no no no no no no no no no I
believe the person choice but bro I'm
gonna be honest I'm you know I have I
have trust in my source I believe in my
sauce here but bro if Drake or one of
these guys or the reason why we that's
the girl no no no no but no but we'll
see again yeah but we're not gonna put
us her and Drake's um
yeah yeah well I trust her but I don't
want to feel that type of pain so James
King in it Drake yeah
Drake as examples because no you're all
right you might be Drake to another you
know what I mean yeah
so for someone like you that's obviously
very confident with women a little you
know I mean like like you said 3.5 years
you've been out here doing your thing um
you see a lot of women like you are the
guy that guys worry about because even
with even with a go of a man you are
still dangerous and the problem is
you're over here acting like oh no no
bro guys worry about you like like so
he's not down to the girl though come on
bro no but it's also down to the
environment and guys like you you have
to put some guys are just slick some
guys have got bars some guys have got we
he might have all of these things and
then just that moment with the alcohol
she makes a mistake you see that mistake
yeah yeah that mistake in that one
second yeah where my wife didn't have a
sense uh we could maybe go over
something but that one mistake you're
trying to that mistake it's another
Choice thank you Brit yeah
bro flip it back onto US yeah I don't
care what you say like you could have
the most beautiful women sitting at home
yeah a woman a woman of some women do
know how much power they can have over a
man that they they can be so seductive
and very clever in the way that they act
the way they talk a woman can [ __ ] with
her eyes so I mean if she wants to I
mean so have you ever been [ __ ] with a
woman's eyes
you could put the same scenario on the
other side is in the fact that like we
us boys gone a lot of holidays together
we've grown up we go all over the world
together and some of them and lovely
committed relationships and then boys
stay solid and they are they're around
our single boys who are around a lot of
single girls and are doing this that and
the other and those boys have to stay
solid yeah they're in them they're in
their food and they do and we're in them
Villas they're winning scenarios and the
boys like boys I'm going to bed because
they and they take themselves at that
scenario away from that scene because
they've got beautiful women around them
can I just say something that is the
first I've heard about
I haven't heard about women taking
himself out the scene
the first time I've heard about men
absolutely taking himself out of things
absolutely I agree I've never no but you
would find that with me old school girls
go together we leave together we come
back together yeah our boys our boys are
making it sound now is respectable
completely
women cheat as well as men oh my God
very comfortable our boys our boys will
get cabs homeboy speaking on behalf of a
woman women cheat as well as much oh my
God
I should play innocent women cheap but
who cheats is it modern women or
traditional women modern Auntie no no
I'm going to stop you actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna caveat now
wait a minute let me speak my
grandmother yeah is she the best woman
in the world your grandmother now yeah
yeah she she pretty much raised me yeah
my grandmother pretty much raised me
since I was a kid yeah and she's the
most old-school traditional woman in the
world yeah and she's lived a life more
than I could ever imagine
and trust me it doesn't matter what age
or what where you were where you're from
it has happened from women and men since
back in the day but what I'm trying to
say is that I can understand what you're
saying from your grandma's point of view
because there are more women than men so
sooner or later someone's got to double
up but it's the way they're doubling up
in the old days
you know you had like old people growing
up then you had people like your
grandmother who had a man out there and
you'd only meet together at funerals and
then realize that you've got all these
cousins and families
I understand absolutely but now the
women the modern women they don't want
to double up unless it's like threesomes
and foursome sometimes they stay away
mad old world right and
they want to be they're not the
respectable side chick of course I
understand that because in the old days
I knew who you were yeah the man was
married he had another family he can
take care of you and take care of the
family but I find that
the modern women now they just and this
is what I'm saying to Auntie about
earlier about saying listen some girls
you know what level you're on together
yeah she's about that and right we never
judge I don't care I don't care how many
people you slept with I couldn't get I
don't know I've never asked that
question because I don't care because
you shouldn't ask me that question if
I'm never going to tell you so you
should because it's none your business
okay yeah I don't care what you've done
in your past history before wait but
wait when you say that you don't care
because you're not gonna marry them or
not you know what even with Partners I
wouldn't ask that question man so so
okay so if you go ahead I'm different so
people had 50 bodies
no I'm not saying I'm saying you don't
know but if I knew the girl that yours
we've had 100 buddies yeah you wouldn't
mind I'd say to yourself no I'm saying
I'm saying so go having 100 bodies you
would you know I said how can I judge
yeah no I'm not asking you to judge I'm
just saying to you like personally
that's what I'm saying when you sleep
with a girl the way I validate you is
what I can't judge you on stuff you've
done in your past compared if I've done
the same thing
no it goes back to what we're saying
earlier men and women are different
because you have to get you you have to
I love you
some birds can just literally get it on
a plate I know mate I know if she if she
might have had XYZ history but sometimes
people's lives okay okay cool let me
flip it around let me let your lying in
the bed with your babies one day she
said look babes I love you in it and I
just want to be honest with you I'm just
going to tell you in it yeah
um
uh I uh I made like a video and I got
banged out about 20 men at one time
um wait wait that come on that's wait
hold on a second about me turn around
saying about a gangbang with 30 birds
and it's just me I mean what's the
difference between 100 sleep of 100 men
I sleep over 20 people in one go yeah in
one go on a video that's come on yeah
come on that's well extreme
so there's no wait a minute
come on because everyone's so stupid all
right okay okay let me take out a video
let me check out the video
she had a 20-man lineup yeah come on no
why because you're getting a come on but
why it's not different take it take this
like Kanye and Kim yeah she made one six
but I'm gonna expose anybody here about
anything like that but you're trying to
tell me you ain't made a sex tape we've
been missing that before of course you
have like but because Ray J exposed that
all of a sudden she's a slack she's not
a snake she made a sex tape with my man
I'm asking a question so so I don't
understand how 100 years 100 bodies
go that's come on
but listen it's not not to a man to me
yeah it's not no difference and let me
tell you something you slept with a
hundred if you slept with 20 men in one
goal or 20 minutes at one time to me
personally you still slept with 20 man
there's no caveat you let 20 minutes
when you actually meet someone do you
actually ask them about their body count
I've never had anybody else do you
actually um
four years and even when was dating he'd
never even asked me when was he died
I'm not ashamed of the person I haven't
set up for loads of people no no but I'm
being real like he should if that was my
son
I'm gonna go ask her for you like end of
the day
because because
four years down now you should have been
knowing about yourself
the woman that's about to marry my son
I'm coming to my family actually that's
not appropriate no no hold on hold on a
second actual fact if we take it back to
original wear it for me it is very
appropriate because this is what's the
problem that has happened right
originally what used to happen was all
that happened was I had good promise and
your dad will come and check me the
reason why you women going what is this
wait wait wait hold on listen the reason
you women can't pick men this is why you
always pick the guys that that break
your hearts in that sleep hold on a
second that's why I've got a boyfriend
okay you yeah so let's talk about all
the all the the majority of the women
that have come in this show they keep
moaning about the types of men that they
got but it's the men that you pick
because you
because you types of men you keep men
know how to pick up the [ __ ] from
other men the moment we coming listen
every time a guy meets a mum and
someone's mom the mom loves him oh he's
so nice he saw this but he might have
the worst plans for your daughter but he
knows how to sweeten up the mum the
moment the brother the dad sees him they
know are going straight away us men can
pick out other men's so if you go and
bring this guy to me I can tell whether
or not this guy is going to be a Tyrone
or Chad or Putin and we've got lots of
sisters yeah I've got three older or
younger um two older one younger all
married all over the child okay now I'm
just asking because you sound like
something that's really protective that
yeah
but my Mom this is the thing yeah like
my mum taught us about value like to
understanding it like no one's telling
nobody that you shouldn't have a life
you shouldn't go out there but there's
certain things that people don't do all
this if someone hasn't claimed you if
you don't have a ring on your finger you
are single the only way a man can avoid
not speaking to you Outsiders when I
look on your finger and I know that you
I know that you're married apart from
that everyone's up for game this guy
might be your boyfriend today but you
God willing that you guys go on to get
married but there's no trouble okay cool
but a lot of people think that so unless
he's got a ring on your finger another
man potentially can taste nothing that
means nothing no no no no but in life in
life means nothing happened to anyone
nothing to anyone a ring means nothing
to anyone what about your parents your
mum and dad they're married for 45 years
seven years I would say 47 years well
extra two years and you're gonna say
that means nothing it means everything
but what no no no nothing
attractive I
don't if I'm still gonna chat to her
you see I mean
yeah
right years ago women used to wear
wedding rings
to get rid of the men and then after a
while I realized that it doesn't work
men are attracted to where they ring so
they like to test the bouncers
hello if I'm going to in a place where I
know that I'm going to hit on I put my
my this finger I put it onto my other
finger does it stop people why no no why
would you do no because I just think you
know what I want to go out I want to
have a good time but I still respect my
man and I'd like to reduce the amount of
people
you just said at the beginning
do you realize right that there is a big
difference in what you're saying because
you're going on like yeah more modern
this and that but when you want to go
out and you be safe you're wearing
something traditional yeah is this
traditional yeah what do you think why
did you put it on that finger why don't
you put it on your big toe
[Laughter]
clothes as you like you can drink
tequila you can go with your girls but
you never said that you had the wedding
ring as a backup plan
that makes a big difference
I wouldn't say that you're you're a
traditional woman I think you're you're
trying hard I hope you get there yeah
facts you're trying hard not to be
honest with you because what you're
doing in well yeah that don't make no
difference making your husband stop
wearing the ring yeah
I said that but Auntie what I'm trying
to say is that you are choosing
bits and pieces you're choosing the
traditional that works for you
no I'm talking about you and not just
work for me I'm talking about you you're
choosing the traditional
the things that like you say a
traditional woman's supposed to do the
the clothes the food the cooking the
caring for your man and everything but
then you've got the modern side which
the traditional woman wouldn't do but
then when it suits you
then you're using the ring to show
people like you know what
keep away from me
no no wait I'll finish of course and
that is exactly
what he was saying ages ago yep that's
exactly what he was saying now if you
turned around and said yes I wear all
these skimpy clothes and I go out and I
might know trust me and I wear the
wedding ring as extra it would have made
a big difference to how I perceived you
that's me then sorry for not saying that
it would have made a it would have made
a big difference but Auntie that is me
because I want to drink what I want and
where I want now what I'm trying to say
is that and I'll wear this what I'm
trying to say is that you can't have it
obviously you know that a wedding ring
makes a big difference otherwise you
wouldn't wear it I've got a caveat wait
a minute let me switch it onto a second
but why can't I with the wedding ring
the fake wedding ring go out and wear
what I want and feel comfortable and
dance and that's even worse but I don't
I don't want people to touch me still so
if I've got the the one in a minute is
that is that good or bad hang in a
minute when so when people are going out
and you've got the wedding ring is there
a chance that they will try and touch
you of course
so have anybody ever touched you when
you go out without your wedding ring of
course
but why can't I it's the fact that I
still have the boyfriend that lets me go
out and do what I want to do but I'll
connect you but you're an independent
woman he lets you because he feels
comfortable with me doing that if he
didn't then it'd be a different story
but he still feels so comfortable with
me going out where what I want drinking
the tequila wearing what I want one and
all that stuff so if he didn't you
wouldn't though if he didn't
your boyfriend's Simpson
what I want to get to is that
when you put the ring on what situations
do you feel that you're in I just feel
more that you need to put it on like I
feel more give us a scenario you're
going out tell us where you are what
you're wearing what you're doing and
when you decide to put the ring always
brick caveat I want to say be honest
because I know from a from a man she's
already said mace don't stop a geyser
does it it doesn't it doesn't stop a guy
but the thing is I could go out in a
tracksuit going to the shop there's a
guy that's going to try it with me or I
could go out on a skimpy outfit in a
club and dance how I want to dance he's
going to still try with me so from me
going out of course it's gonna hide in
the church now you said the shop thing
would you wear the ready ring to go to
the shop if you knew gonna get hit on no
of course right so you wear it you wear
it if you know you're going to get hit
on the necklace
why is she going out into a hostile
environment oh so I want to have fun I
wanna in a half of an environment am I
supposed to stay at home Auntie am I
supposed to sit home no is this what
modern women modern women okay if we're
going on this yeah they're supposed to
stay at home so their men can go out do
what they want but you can't you've got
to stay at home just in case men are
gonna move to you because
you said that is that what you believe
traditional women do that's what I'm
asking that's what I'm asking is that
what traditional women no because no
traditional women they go out
they enjoy themselves safely and they do
not go into hostile environments
[Music]
in this day and age everywhere is
hostile
wait a minute let Auntie speak I'll tell
you where I go I go to shows I go to
festivals it's a Godiva Festival I go to
festivals I go to theaters I go to shows
I will go and I would concerts listen to
music and that is where I go there's no
music I can't go to a club anymore then
Auntie no I didn't say that you couldn't
go to a club environment if you want to
put yourself why would it's not logical
why would you want to put yourself in a
hostile environment the word is in there
everywhere everywhere
wait let me finish it's not everywhere
because I go out regular and I don't go
in hostile environments okay
why would you say why would you go into
an environment that you say is hostile
because I still want to have fun and it
doesn't matter how I where I want to
have fun it doesn't matter them hostile
environments is the places I want to
have fun so the modern I'm not asking
them to be in hostile I could go to a
club and have friends like a dance with
my friends but it's still going to be
hostile because the people there are
making it hostile where do I go have fun
if the places I want to have fun guys
are making it hostile I'm gonna tell me
where I'm going guys are making up angle
a minute so what is in these
environments
definite I want to know where is it that
you go
what makes it hostile and what what
happens there now what happens there the
men you got them where do you go I could
go I want right tell me where you go to
have fun I'm gonna go have fun with my
friends of a group of girls I want to go
dance I just want to just want to take a
look
you want to go out with your friends
friends female friends female friends
free my friends yeah you want to go and
dance dance yeah I Wanna Dance yep I
want to drink yeah I want to wear what I
want to want
but then in these places there are the
guys that make it a hostile environment
so if the same place is that I want to
do the things where I want to dance I
want to listen to music I want to listen
to on a drink what I want to drink but
the guys are there that make it hostile
where do I go tell me where I want to go
those things that you like yeah that you
can't find them anywhere else but in a
hostile environment no no because like
guys are there like Mason said earlier
places have become hostile they have
before so you could go somewhere before
and things could be so chilled Good
Vibes whatever but now it's changed so
what should I stop going to the place
yes yes yes
we're not talking about the a guy or
having a man I'm just mean in general
the place is being hostile why should I
have to change what I like because I
like house music and I like going to
house festivals and we are why should I
not go we are now because there's guys
there like a hospital yeah I've been to
there's house first there's festivals
out there that are not hospitals
teach the guys not to be still and then
if you if there's hang in a minute
there's these hostile environments women
are going to the environments and
they're hostile
the men out there are hostile the men
are making it hostile
why the women go in because they love it
where do we go
things have changed so much
attention you do you do right because
you've got Jamie Jones headline and
that's what you do you do you do I've
just listen I'm just listening wait a
minute I've just listened to you women
tell me about going into hostile dangers
I've listened to you that was your words
we didn't put those words in your mouth
you said hostile you talked about all
these different things that had it in
there and now you want to talk about do
you realize if the place is hostile is
dangerous for for me as a man I've been
um I've been stabbed before I know what
it feels like so when you guys are
talking about hostile environment
someone listening to you you guys have
no idea what it is when you get in a
real hostile environment the dangers of
it so you're telling me about a place
where it's dangerous I'm not talking
about I'm not talking about somewhere
where it's just you know something might
have it's hostile the word hostile means
dangerous
let me carry on let me carry on let me
carry on and the only thing you want to
tell me is oh um like there's no a place
you can go there's so many places in the
world you can go you I like wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute you
guys do not mitigate risk you as women
do not mitigate risk you treat every
risk is the same not all risk is the
same and this is why you get yourself
put in scenarios you're going to a place
where the manner grab you grabby grabby
the man don't know how to act have me
raised right but yet you still want to
go then when something bad happens you
want to start crying and then you've got
a man at home wait a minute who told you
but you might at home I said babe why
did you put yourself in that scenario
we go for the music
favorite DJs there I want to go and I
want to listen to that music why should
I not go because guys it meant to be
aggressive trying to buy yeah Dubai is
meant to be very safe yeah I've been
trying to buy a few times there we lived
me and yo lived out there for five six
weeks right we know a lot of people out
there a lot of promoters out there a lot
of people live out there and live live
an amazing life where we was out there
we heard about two or three people
getting stabbed left right and Center we
go to them clubs and we have the best
time ever we know girls out there that
go and have a great time Dubai is
I can walk around Dubai yeah with a with
a with a handful of diamonds like this
and no one will touch me I can walk
around East London with a handful of
diamonds like that and it'd be gone
within about 10 seconds right so Dubai I
know girls that went to Dubai mate and
they've been harassed left right and
Center in the clubs by white boys London
boys birming and boys live doesn't
matter where you're from but it doesn't
matter where you are as long as there's
geezers here I don't care who you are
what environment private event good
event I don't care where you are
in a minute so wait a minute you're
trying to tell me that anywhere women go
to enjoy themselves
anywhere that women go and they're men
there yeah
that's rubbish that's rubbish
I'm not gonna accept that because what
you're doing now is you're saying no no
hold on you're saying that whatever man
goes
no because what you're doing is you're
gonna you're gonna demonize Men You're
Gonna demonize men you two as men should
not be saying anywhere that men is
hostile I'm not gonna have that no no no
no no no no no no
wait a minute it can be it does not mean
it is there's a difference in the word
so so let's not do that wait a minute
when a girl was on the show and she said
that Owen in my welcome majority of men
no but you know do you know what the
majority is
said in in Dubai it's the safest place
I'm a man and you're saying when these
men is
if you choose to put yourself in a place
that is dangerous and hostile you accept
some responsibility for your behavior if
I'm your man and you put yourself in a
place where man I grab your grabby don't
know how to act wait a minute wait a
minute not every single place you go to
his life
thank you you're trying to say right yes
but only what I'm saying to you right
what you're trying to what you're saying
is bro you're saying is if you're
putting yourself if the girls are
putting themselves in a situation of a
guy's way grabby grabby it shouldn't be
happening hang on a second I know girls
that go to places in situations that
aren't grabby grabby that aren't
renowned for that sort of [ __ ] unless
there's a difference between going to a
club and getting hit on and rejecting it
time and time again right there's
difference in going out okay and there's
a difference from going somewhere where
you are describing it as hostile for
example I went to Carnival and I found
it very hostile because when I said no
to guys they got aggressive but I'm not
gonna to go around and say oh it's just
hostile but it can be okay will you go
there again yeah I would still in the
same situation again I would still go
because it's how I handle myself but
it's not starting would you handle
yourself differently or would you do the
same thing I did yeah but hang in a
minute would you describe Carnival as
being hostile or saying Carnival can be
hostile very hostile you say it is
an apostle thing going on whether it's
me or not there's always some sort of
hostile situation going on and kind of
where am I right that's why so you're
saying
the carnival can be hostile
no majority of the time not majority
they always use that word majority so
when they don't mean a majority means
like 70 of Carnival is hostile you know
what you're doing you're doing what the
TV what the media do yeah a few people
get um get stabbed in economy a few
things happen and they call Carnival
this has happened so the majority of
Carnival is not hostile it's across two
days
let me land because I'm not going to
have it because what you're doing is
yeah Carnival some bad things happen at
carnival there's some idiots that go to
Carnival we know stabbing tapping in
carnival but the most for the most part
you will not see a damn thing for the
two days it tends to be after dark about
nine o'clock when the things start to
happen so Carnival is not a hostile
Place
wait guys sorry
the only reason I've mentioned Carnival
is because I'm saying because we're
talking about hostile environments so
I'm saying we could class that as but I
still go so that's that's not good
because
it can be hostile wait a minute the
difference is is that now she's saying
it can be you're changing the life
no it can't be no you said it you said
it is you said it is yeah no I
experienced it but it's because you've
experienced it doesn't mean that what
we're trying to say is like the same for
the Moroccan girls I don't like it we're
not saying Carnival is not hostile
Carnival can
yeah I got to Carnival if I went to
Carnival and I find it hostile am I
gonna go back no I bet you would no no
no no no no no
listen a minute hang in a minute
Listen to I said I said if I went to
Carnival and I found it hostile would I
go back no the key word is hostile okay
I don't care because I you said oh but
you'll be having fun I cannot have fun
in a hostile environment so I would not
go back
24 7 though there could be a moment
where you feel like oh this
environment's hostile so you know how
Carnival it is
then but then you could go around the
corner you could go Rampage for example
I've been Rampage it was very hostile
then when I went to school
no I'm just giving an example I'm giving
an example
there could be a reason
it's a lot of
money thank you it's not always hostile
and there could be an environment worse
you think okay that's a bit hostile but
regardless of that minute situation
you've had a good time throughout the
rest of the day did you get it so then
you want to go so answer you could go to
any I could name you I could give you a
list of 10 clubs I've been to in our
beefar in Vegas in Bali in London in
Maidstone in Ken like that are all
amazing you could all go to but I could
name every single one of those that I've
seen a punch up I've seen a stab in I've
seen someone's heads get kicked in like
how many times have you had a good time
it's not a hostile it was a hostile
environment at that time I've been to we
are Festival five six what I'm trying to
say is that um would not say that it's a
hostile environment you would say that
it can be it can be accepting can be I
will not accept that Carnival there's a
hostile environment
can be anywhere can be of course
wait let me finish if something or
somewhere yeah is continually in my view
a hostile environment I don't give a
[ __ ] what kind of music they're playing
now
I'm not going yeah because it's already
proven that it's a hostile environment
so I find it really hard that as a woman
that there is nowhere that I can go out
where there's men that is not going to
be hostile because I think you said can
be okay I I accept that aren't you you
can go to certain places and they might
be incidents that's a hospital right
that you might find hostile yeah right
you can live with that but if I keep on
going somewhere where time and time and
time again it is hostile what the hell
am I putting myself
especially as a woman it's not correct
so especially as a woman this question
Auntie though so let's say that you've
gone to Carnival you've gone to Carnival
for the last five years you have time
you do what you're doing and this one
time you go and you're in a hostile
environment you think I'm in a hostile
environment the next slime that comes
around are you going back even though
you've just been in that one hostile
environment that's why I haven't been my
life's too important that's what I
haven't been that's basically what
happened that is why that and that is
why I wouldn't go back like I said to
you I've been in the flow I've been on
the truck I've been with the DJs I've
been everywhere in carnival and if I was
going to go to Carnival now and I took
my grandkids I would go on a Sunday and
I'd make sure by four o'clock that we're
leaving and that we're gone I refuse to
go Carnival because
let me finish if I was gonna go Carnival
I would buy a costume and I would go in
a float if I really had the need to why
would you finish I would fine why would
you finish at four why did I finish
before four o'clock you said you'd be
gone by four why because like I said
I'll take my grandchildren and I think
that on a Sunday and it's coming down
all the Hostile things happened late at
night no late at night I wouldn't be
there that I wouldn't put myself in that
situation because so everybody that
keeps on going Carnival knows that
people go Carnival and they go early
no traditional people oh aren't they I
can't agree no traditional people who
enjoy Carnival would be at carnival of
eight nine ten o'clock at night unless
unless let me finish okay unless you're
with a sound system with a cook with the
bands with the flow or something like
that but I could give you clubs that
we've been to for if you know what
you're wanting a matter for half a dozen
years and we've had the best nights ever
at weekends at a time but then I've been
to that same club and I've seen people
have their heads kicked in so look I'll
still go there the next time so Mason
look look what is the meaning of a
hostile environment the environment can
become hostile when unwelcome on conduct
harassment it okay
you're stopping me you're stopping I'm
not gonna say to you so if you're in a
hostile environment yeah all these
places we're talking about what hostile
environment is so when you use the word
hostile it's dangerous
so so difference between it can be you
could that's the key word
can I just ask a question when you went
to Carnival and it was hostile what
exactly happened to you that made it
guys were trying to talk to me and then
when I said no they got they ended up
getting aggressive but obviously that
hasn't happened to me in previous years
so that's why I'm not saying oh
Carnival's hostile I always go so how
many people got aggressive about at
least three so that's not so free out of
how many thousands of people
three people approached you to developed
people
that were five ten yeah didn't take no
fun answer no they just kept on yeah so
that makes
no then they started being abusive and
what did you do I just like told them
who was you with my friends female
friends yeah how many wow why should
that matter honey what should that
matter it shouldn't but we're living in
the real world exactly exactly
that is why that is why I'm saying that
like he was saying as a woman there's
certain situations you put yourself into
because like you're agreeing with me now
these things happen and if you know
these things can happen anywhere
anywhere why would you put yourself in
there
and in a minute they are safer ways of
enjoying Carnival
there are safer ways of enjoying clubs
I'm not going to say that I haven't been
into Cubs
what I'm going to say is that I refuse
to go into clubs where I feel that
I know completely of course and what
we're saying anywhere I don't care where
you go we could go into the normal quiet
apartment just so happens one night the
two geezers bump into each other to
[ __ ] hate each other and all hell
erupts in that club that's not a hostile
environment
that is an incident happening that Pub
is not a hostile environment
see that Pub it's hostile but I wouldn't
want to go in there if you told me you
were into that Pub and a fight happened
to break out that's totally different
but we are festivals yeah any
environment
we are festivals a massive group for
many many US boys love a festival we
love Ghana we love going to clubs love
going all over the country and all over
the world as we are festivals started to
go on over the years it started to bring
in the wrong crowds and we start to see
the wrong stuff happening at that place
and what changed that environment the
people that we still went back Auntie
just because that it's not their
environment we love we are
DJ love the music
yeah it can be I've seen I've seen we've
we've been walking out the end of the
event but I've seen someone covered in
Claret from head to toe where's your
friends
I think that my interpretation of
hostile and your interpretation of
hostile is totally different because if
I went somewhere yeah and the fight
broke out yeah right two people in the
corner and like bounces are there and
shut it down yeah yeah yeah yeah as far
as I'm concerned yeah
no but I wouldn't turn around and say
live would I that is hostile I was
saying you know what I went out the
other day and they got some idiots
that's what I'm saying to you I don't
believe anywhere it's hostile I just
know [ __ ]
let me speak let me speak you guys are
capable hostile was nice style hang a
minute hostile was not my word
hostile was not my word it was Britney's
the young lady's words she's the one
that brought up the word hostile that
she goes out to hostile environment and
the men in there make it hostile
that's where it is so wherever she goes
that's what she's saying yeah that she
wants to go those places and they're
hostile that is why I wanted to know
what hostile meant because she didn't
say these places can be hostile or these
places like now I realize that hervey of
hostile and mine is different because
I'm used to going to Carnival and
they're three or four or 10 men approach
me and they're drunk and it's like yeah
I'll get I'll be getting on and that to
me that's not hostile that is it's
normal Carnival Carnival because they
got aggressive obviously I'm just no I'm
trying to say is that with alcohol in
them people ask a certain way to me
that still wouldn't be hostile for me I
would not see that as a hostile
environment so our experiences are
different you went to Carnival that
happened to you you said it was hostile
if I went to Carnival I would say I had
a good time there were a few drunken
idiots you know what I mean hostile the
word in general so let's say aggressive
behavior or something but you're
changing it now you didn't say that no
but I didn't say no but you but you went
with it no no but I'm because obviously
that's the word we've surrounded in but
I'm saying like just in general drama
happening or five yeah but but I think
that's all because what I'm trying to
say now is that now that word hostile is
removed yeah I can understand why you'd
go back to Carnival yeah yeah I mean
that makes sense because you can't judge
it you can't judge an event
the young lady there said that all the
places she goes to where she's got a
music this that whatever that all
hostile where is she supposed to go and
that's what I'm trying to understand
like if something is the word hostile
why would you keep putting yourself in
that situation if it's hostile there
must be other places to go like he's
saying festivals and their eyes might
kick out and everything but I wouldn't
say that I've been t-faced no they're
not hostile I wouldn't say that to your
face
Auntie why I look for from a man's point
of view when we say a place is hostile a
rave do you know what that means for a
man when you say a place is hostile it
means that people can be in there with
knives I mean they were guns it's going
to be very tough that's what I was
thinking so me as a guy I would look to
a place and say yeah like not because
we're shook because we know when you say
people who do you mean no so I'm talking
about when you who do you mean men or
women men yeah no yeah because earlier
you early accused me of like the
say amen and the problem no I don't
believe me okay okay
okay you don't ever hear women yeah so
but when you say a hostile environment
for a man you know what in my in my
vision when I hear hostile I think this
is going to be the maddest place man I'm
gonna meet in there with they haven't
been searched they're going to be in
there with puffer jackets probably
Bally's in you know one of those places
where your back is going to be against
the wall and you're never gonna chill
yes that's the hostile environment if I
go to an event and I don't realize it's
going to be one of these and I find
myself in here I want to get out as soon
as possible now the reason I want to get
out as soon as possible is not because
I'm shook not because we can't handle
ourselves because I know from a hostile
environment complacement is real what
can happen now let's say someone tries
to try me in a hostile environment yeah
this is what women don't understand
about men this is why we don't you think
differently oh it's hostile oh men are
there then when I'm in a hostile
environment get hostile to me that can
resolve resort to something else someone
could pull something out now I might be
innocent as hell but I have to defend
myself now yeah I end up taking off
something taking some something of
somebody and doing them in I was
innocent I put myself on hostile and
right when I could have left now I'm
gonna end up in jail not because not
because not because I've done anything
but because I've defended myself now I
have to go and in court and explain why
I've defended myself in a hostile
environment you guys don't understand
what men have to perceive because you
haven't been put any scenarios when you
put yourself in a hostile environment
you take away all the parameters of
safety you do not control it anymore if
a guy wants to punch you up slap you up
he can you have to deal with that later
on if a guy wants to try to pop my chain
if a guy wants to try to stab me I have
to deal with that later on this is what
happens when you put yourself in a
hostile environment Carnival is not one
of those places because I would never
put myself in there and if you know as a
lady you have a man and you go to places
where man don't respect you man will
don't respect your man please stop
putting yourself in these scenarios
because it is dangerous it is not safe
enough to say men should be different
because yes men should be different I
got three sisters and a mother and I
believe that men should be different but
in reality men aren't different but not
everybody is not me no no no but you're
saying that's everywhere but we have
risk we have low risk and high risk I
agree with that women still everywhere
yeah but but what we need to do is know
um there's probability of us a
possibility I agree with that yeah
what's the possibility versus the
problem sorry what's the possibility of
this thing happening this is how we
mitigate
so if you put yourself in a place where
Mana grabby grab it you don't respect
then you're more likely to encounter men
that actually might put a scenario like
that so when we talk about hostile it's
just the wording that was used because
Carnival that's what the media tend to
do they tend to something tends to
happen and they blow it up and they say
but you have to understand man a
carnival are gonna touch you that's I
it's it's not my thing I don't do that
but that's but that's how Madness
I don't care where you go bro geezers
will always try to touch up but Carnival
they're going to touch you they're going
to attack the ground like don't get me
wrong I know that happens in carnival
but men shouldn't just touch women but
what we're doing what we're doing is
talking about what I believe men
shouldn't be doing you believe what men
should be doing versus what the men are
actually no I know what I'm just saying
so answer your question is that the only
time you've been Carnival only here have
you been kind of anywhere else no no
yeah but like I said I don't think it's
generally hostile but I said that
experience obviously I didn't like but
previously that's not happened to me so
obviously I just think year after year
it gets worse because the people that
tend to come and want to cause trouble
so okay
and um the young lady now you've been
listening
and you're a modern woman
traditional woman
[Music]
are you still
I'm still for 350. you're still 50 50.
so you're still fine there's nothing
that you've heard here that have even
caused you to think of it
no
there's traditional there's traditional
make it right there's traditional is
that is that right is that the right way
no that's the whole question it's modern
Commodore women be traditional yeah she
said she was 50 50 half and half cookie
do me a favor on that when you say can
modern women be traditional can you just
elaborate on what you feel as though
traditional in today's world means for a
woman because traditional is always
right I think traditionals having
self-respect in yourself and young man
but you could can you expand on that for
me and jump
in terms of self-respect like what does
that cover for you what does that when I
step out of the house I'm representing
my man okay yeah but whatever I do I'm
really step in the moment when I was a
child and I stepped out of the house I
was representing my mum and dad now when
I step out the house I represent my man
so as a traditional woman anything can I
do yep I need to remember that I'm
reflecting on him okay I appreciate that
everything I agree with you and I mean
everything from cooking cleaning
anything managing money anything I do as
a traditional woman I've always got him
Forefront yeah
does that make your view correct yeah I
I agree do you think is that your right
way I didn't say it's the right way
that's what I'm expecting I'm asking
them cool the question is which is which
so Auntie when you talk about
traditional wage about cooking cleaning
don't you think the Giza should do that
as well
there you go there you go
the difference is
people get this Twisted okay right they
want they always say they want 50 50.
who who says that me women
right yeah 50 50 might work for some
people uh-huh right but with me yeah we
both make decisions but he makes the
final one on what everything everything
okay but is that your choice everything
too much you know how easy it is right
to get something and to say do you know
what
especially if it's money yeah yeah I'll
get it right and you say there's I'll
give you all of that and you just deal
with it yeah and I just okay I just
don't have to worry about it I get it it
doesn't take away from my Independence
it doesn't take away from whatever I
agree in the fact do you also appreciate
and agree the fact that if your partners
was to sit down and and talk about it
that you come to a mutual agreement
rather than just letting the Giza deal
with it all
I would say that we talk about it he
comes to the final decision because we
don't always the final decision is
always his I don't want the finals do
you appreciate in the modern day and age
where men and women as a couple will sit
down and have that discussion together
and come to a mutual agreement but
you're making it sound like I don't sit
down and discuss don't do that
traditional people will do that you
don't just say oh the man's gonna need
but you have just said that no matter
what you have that discussion he still
makes that final decision because if I
say European
my opinion doesn't matter otherwise he
wouldn't listen to me my opinion matters
and it's not all the time that
women are always in this winning all
right then if you want to put it that
way it's not all the time that I lose
sometime I might win but at the end of
the day the final decision says okay so
when do you win then if his final
decision is his I don't want to win it's
not about winning because it's never a
competition it's never a competition
that's what we may feel to realize it is
never a competition because there is no
decision that my man would make that
will put me at a detriment okay
so because I trust him so much with me
I will let him deal with it because I
will always come better off and as a
woman sometimes I might say no I don't
agree with that but I would just say you
know what go with it and nine times out
of ten he's always right if you don't
agree with it then his your man's still
making the decision no I will tell I
will say do you know what I'll agree to
disagree you go you go and do it and
nine times out of ten he's right okay
look the thing about it because he would
discuss it and he's got more he might
have more experience about something you
know
I've got a certificate in car
maintenance I can service a car do you
know what I mean so there's lots of
things that I can do that I don't you
know that I don't I just think honey I
think this whole thing where where
especially like with modern modern women
and even what you're prescribing to
Mason is that if if a woman allows a man
to make decisions
that it diminishes us you have to
understand men and women have different
superpowers there's a lot of power and
femininity and this is the problem like
a lot of people keep forgetting this
that women have so much power
um if they acting within their powers
power structure but you're always trying
to do things where a lot of times we're
met what I think traditionally masculine
things where men will do for um Auntie
to allow her partner to take the lead it
doesn't diminish an actual fact she's
saying right these certain things I
don't need to worry about because I try
so much in you she's not going to let
the man take her to take her to the edge
of a cliff and push her off the cliff of
course she's not stupid but at the same
time she doesn't need to be
um questioning his judgment if he leads
that any way she doesn't deem to be fit
she's gonna let him know and if he
carries on doing it he can go but at
some point you guys know it okay
well even at that point she said because
there's a way they can work her out but
my thing is this as long as you guys are
not willing to submit and when I say
submit this there's some nice people
need to have a nasty connotation with
the word submit submit doesn't mean
um getting on one knee and and
worshiping your man it means trusting
these leaders yes which means he's not
going to lead me down the wrong path and
as long as you guys keep fighting
because you said you've been in your
mouth for four years and you're younger
so that's really good like I want to see
you guys progress I don't want you to be
one of these girls out in the first he's
mad because no because that's what
happens what happens is if you prescribe
to a lot of the things that people say
you might get a good guy
and you might end up losing this good
guy and then you're gonna go along the
pathway and then you get Alpha widowed
you never find another guy that's good
at this guy I didn't just end up being
out in your 30s and you get mad you end
up like a lot of these girls in the
house waves so I'm saying to you and
this is what happens no no no but I'm
giving you something I'm giving you
something that's not it's not you
because you're 23 and you've got a
manual now but in 10 years time that
could easily be you 33 and these are the
women that I interact with and by the
time they get to this age they are mad
they're frustrated they've got high body
counts and they've got unagable
attitudes and they're not willing to
change and that's all they bring us men
and then they meet men like yo and he
runs through them quickly do you know
why no no simply it means right right
quickly
no but what I mean is end of the day is
is is like we're trying to give you some
information because obviously you're a
bit younger and you've got a man that
the man that loves you by the end of the
day if you want to play the game you can
play this game and and that that little
thing where you had the U for youth upon
you which makes you better than a lot of
these other girls you're going to lose
that everyone gets older you know what
I'm trying to say to you and then you
don't become that 23 year old in the
club no more no them in actual fact you
become that older woman that let a lot
of opportunities that goes I'm not I'm
not that woman not no but you're not but
they're not making a good point I know
you are not her there's a lot of women
that are yeah I am not sure so I am not
sure you know what I find that's really
hard gone a lot of women talk but they
don't listen no they don't listen
because he's trying to give you the best
advice I know you're not you're not even
letting him
finishing I mean I'm finishing I'm
talking now and he's going to give you
just I was gonna give you some advice
and he was just talking some of my sense
because because I feel like you're
agreeing with him um no because I'm not
capable
constantly not because he's a man
because I agree with you when you said
that you turned down right I agreed with
you when you were saying about the
fantastic the woman that I hope you're
going to get invite me to the wedding I
agreed with you when you were saying
that you're honest and open and I agree
with him so I'm not just picking I don't
just agree just my thing is this my
thing is this rather than trying to
battle against what a man is saying like
do you keep you want to act like I'm an
anomaly I'm not an anomaly I represent a
lot of men and the problem in the past
is men haven't spoken and a lot of these
guys like him so he keep using you but I
want to use you have an example because
he's a good looking guy that's out there
getting good results they're not going
to tell you this they don't give a damn
about your body count because they're
not going to hang around long enough for
it to matter they're gonna run it up and
give it to your husband but when you
meet a guy like me that actually wants
to marry you and then yo and Mason have
run for your body how has that helped me
what have you done for me so so so me as
a guy I'm saying a lot of these things
because women don't want to listen and
the average man he's not going to say
anything to you because he doesn't want
to risk it being called misogynistic or
you can't tell women what to do with
their bodies as soon as men talk like
this we get shot down I do agree because
you're the only winner guys serious yeah
and I'll be honest with you you like
this is coming from when a man is
serious about you he doesn't waste no
time men know what they want so men
understand that another man can pull up
the ball in a Lambo see your wife and
say oh oh what's your name she's like I
got a man he's like where's your ring
you ain't got a ring and then that's it
because it's not yours it's just your
turn thank you oh wow
can I just ask you a quick question
what's your views on Andrew Tate
do you respect Andrew Tai or are you
against what he believes in like not
like I'll be honest with you
um like I never followed him but I only
I only saw the clip Zone based on
Business and Entrepreneurship and
talking about getting out the Matrix and
those types of stuff those are the
things but all the other stuff that I
saw I saw like obviously a lot of stuff
have been taken out of context but I
also agree that no one should be banned
because even Trump shouldn't be banned
because when you start when you silence
someone all that you say they've got
something to say yeah and there's a lot
more people that are dangerous have more
dangerous views I've not been silenced
the real reason is silence and you take
it's not really about the yes of the
misogyny but it's really more about him
telling men that we need to go to the
gym we need to become entrepreneurs yeah
just stuck after your women yeah we need
to look after women stop stop letting
people like [ __ ] on you this is what's
going to happen in the future to
Communists go out and become make your
money become more and become more
productive and then go out there and
finally get a woman yeah and the most
important things that I remember that
you said it was about letting his woman
go out to clubs of his woman with his
girlfriend with her girlfriends yeah
[Applause]
anyone who doesn't believe Andrew speaks
common citizens because they're not
probably listened to him they've only
listened to sound bites of what he said
taken out a contest to God he's a
misogynist thanks and and that's what I
feel like like not even that was that's
what I feel like that's what I know
because from what I've listened to
Andrew Tate I already know what is like
if you cannot pick if you cannot take
away the little you know some of the
things he says the world
don't listen to how he says it listens
to what he says yeah and so when he's
saying those waffles I'll be like bro
that probably didn't help you what you
said yeah say something else I'll be
like yes and that's what I followed him
for it was all about
um becoming better as a man
um it was all about you know
entrepreneurship building a business all
about treating a woman better in actual
fact
um if you're not ready to be that man
you better just leave that woman like
what you were saying go out there become
productive do these things and then once
you do then come back and do that and
that's what I pretty much got from
agitate yeah that's exactly but you
basically just describe the exactly his
philosophy and what he believes in yeah
I heard a lot about what you said that's
why I asked but that's why I asked you
if you yeah just because I didn't
know what you like like I've got I got
three sisters and my mom and my dad I've
grown up in a family unit like I said
I'm not married that's what marriage for
me that's that's a goal family for me is
is is one of the most important things
and and being out here I can accept some
thoughts I've had in the early years but
like I said
um I fully understand what type of woman
that I want I fully understand what type
of man that I am I I like you said I
don't mind coming and grinding and
giving the money to the woman and saying
to the woman you run the household like
let me you know what I'm trying to say
to you these are these aren't things
yeah these are stress up your head man I
don't want to worry about this stuff
like I don't want to worry about
something no but I trust him I don't
want to worry about it no I don't
understand when people say it comes down
to trust well why are you going to sleep
with somebody don't trust no but this is
your boys back to their entire
conversation about I don't care where
you go you're walking into Australia
with man there but I trust you I don't
trust the man
if my if I said to my man I'm going to a
club yeah and I didn't know about that
club and he knew about the club and he
said you know what I don't think you
should go there because blah blah blah
blah blah even though the choice is mine
even no even though the choice is mine
yeah like you said you might have seen a
couple of fights there he might have
seen a couple of fights might have heard
something that I haven't heard of yeah
I'm gonna give him the benefit of the
doubt but because I mean I'd rather be
safe than sorry and it's not that he's
stopping me from going it's just that
I'm gonna make an informed decision I
get that of course and um I'm gonna
Round Up Now final thoughts
I want to know what you thought about
this show and whether you see yourself
as traditional and modern or whether you
want traditional or modern upper halves
yeah um
so yeah my final thoughts on today was
just that like when you when you're in a
relationship you need to understand that
you're in a relationship and when you're
single well you're single and these two
different things they do these are two
separate things and this goes for men
and goes for women as well like and if
someone when you have a partner if
someone wants requirements from you a
lot of the times you have to think to
yourself right
is this person what this person wants
for me are they asking too much for me
or is this something that I a
relationship
um something that you do within a
relationship so I just think that a lot
of the times people make men out to be
insecure or he doesn't trust me but it's
not that we see a lot of other dangers
as well you know I'm trying to say to
you
um so yeah that's what um that's what
I'll say what else you said aren't you
what else was it
oh yeah so I consider I'm a traditional
man
um I have Traditional Values I you know
I want a traditional woman that's that's
something that that I've seen growing up
I respect traditional women I I'm
inspired by them I've throughout history
there's been loads of them especially
with being an African man a black man
I've seen a lot of you know I mean
inspirational women so for me my mom
I've seen my mom lead you know you
understand like in my house I've seen
what my mom has done but at the same
time my dad my dad was a diplomat and I
you know we were the first generation
from Cameroon to come over here so I saw
the sacrifice of a woman do over this in
this country where my dad was over there
something that many people don't know
about Duty so a lot of the times I speak
I speak this way because I've I've seen
it and now yeah and I see my siblings
now they've got it in a modern era and
I'm like damn other people are raising
um traditional people for my siblings or
someone must be raising someone
traditional for me as well
um so yeah so that's kind of how I look
at it um you know I'm glad to be back
again because the second time I was on
the show so it's good to be with you
aren't you I've seen you you know what I
mean I've seen you and you're hosting
and that and yeah and yeah like yeah 100
um so yeah so on my socials my name is
China
um on Instagram and Tick Tock and yeah
make sure you check out Isis you these
are these are my drinks my frozen drinks
would be fire too they're fine
I really enjoyed being on the show today
um
I feel like I could speak freely was an
interesting subject as well
um I wasn't given any red tape I could
speak freely I'm fully for that like for
reading a speech I hate cancel culture I
hate snowflake generation so I
appreciate it being on this podcast
like anyone who's part of the snowflake
generation
um yeah I really enjoyed it really
enjoyed the subject uh I believe women
can be whatever they want in this day
and age
um I think it all comes down to
perspective and personal morals
um I still would like a woman that's
modern and traditional traditional is
not always correct traditional doesn't
always mean it's the right thing to do
there's a lot of things that are
traditional that are completely
outlandish and not correct at all you go
back from history there's loads of
things that are considered tradition but
are completely wrong to that in today's
day and age so traditional does not mean
correct so I would like Traditional
Values but also I want a modern woman as
well my name is Joseph all my all my
socials every social is at yoyo Hassan
peace
was not traditional
you can't just come you can't just come
on here and just say that when I don't
think traditional I would like to know
your opinion rather than that blank
statement
that you don't like
how how deep do you want me to get
five minutes get as deep as you like oh
before you start because
I just want to know about before you
start I just want to know his parents
are one in a million yeah because they
47 years I want to know somebody you
don't see tradition you know what his
problem is I I think he's haunted by the
happiness
well his parents are so happy and so
content it's just like when I was saying
tradition yeah I was going about the
whole uh consensus of tradition not just
marriage not just relationships I was
talking about going back to anything
like colonialism and we're not living in
those times I'm talking about
traditional
that's still correct that still stands
tradition is something that's gone back
a generation yeah that I seen as that's
what you should do that doesn't mean
it's correct yeah there's loads of
things happen in the past that are
tradition
very wrong hang on a minute if I'm wrong
all I'm hearing is talking I don't
understand what you mean can you just
break it down
what about tradition
is wrong in this day and age
relationships
or anything is it traditional way to
wear traditional women okay okay uh
traditional women
you could technically you couldn't well
it depends again culture region religion
um if you was a Catholic you can have
sex before marriage and that the only
person you could ever sleep with would
be the person that you marry
um today I think that's completely out
the window unless you're okay unless
you're a true Catholic for you if you
want you said that you wanted 50 50 but
you ain't a traditional woman but okay
what I'm trying to say is that what is
wrong with oh then what part of
tradition don't you want your woman to
have I want that to be like I said in
the beginning of the podcast I wanted to
be the maternal no what don't you want
that to happen yeah what Traditional
Values you've told me the good
Traditional Values but if tradition is
oh I know for a billion well not a
billion percent I know I know quite it's
highly unlikely I'm gonna find the woman
that's not had sex before marriage in
this day and age especially the women
that I'm in an environment where I put
myself in environments where they are
it's very if I find my [ __ ] Fair
places
but I'm accepting the fact it's highly
unlikely I'm gonna find a woman that
hasn't had sex before marriage that's a
tradition that I can't out the window
yeah it's out the window it's gone
that's what you asked as an example
right that's one of the examples you
know what that is perfect that's the
main example because I'm hearing so many
people saying that they're 50 50 and I'm
part traditional but if you're not
available
you know and that's what I want to hear
so you don't have to say no more you
cover that well in can I just say
something if you do go to the Middle
East they are still in the realm of
traditional oh yes not even back in the
day you can find women upon women upon
women a lot of men got passports in
there yeah but yo so your parents yeah
um don't they like get on to you like
like oh my parents my parents are the
most supportive
understanding chilled people I could
ever wish for his parents they mostly
say to him go out there and sold you out
oats and don't hurt anybody my dad's
from Morocco my mum's from Scotland and
I've been raised with two angels that
literally have taught me do what you
want just don't hurt anyone in the
process that's right that's what I just
said amen that's what I just said
and now you know
oh wow okay
um
I don't know
um to me we live in a modern world right
so people have very different views now
and we've been a far more independent
than what they once were but I suppose
when it comes to it's not about
traditional this that and the other it
comes down to someone's morals and their
values and so what you do in your past
and your single life is up to you but I
believe it once you meet that individual
that is where you begin to show your
true morals
um in what you believe in and how you
wish to treat someone and be with
someone and respect you have that
individual and how you wish to raise a
family Etc so what you do in your single
life is up to you when you meet that
individual then things change and that's
how you you should act accordingly so do
you want to have more modern values or
Traditional Values uh it's not about I
don't think it's about that like you
live in a modern world you have to live
in in the 21st century now things have
changed but when it comes to your your
morals like I'd like to think I'm I
tried to be in an article gentleman as
much as I can I'll open your car door
for you to get in and out of that car
I'll get out that car to get to open a
car door and let you in it and I'll open
the restaurant door I'll pull out your
chair I'll put your coat on I'll take a
coat off for you so I'm not doing that
for any Nook and crannies
you're a traditional man that is just
going to have a modern woman yeah yeah I
don't understand it because because when
you speak here it's twisted myself
because I don't agree with keeping a
woman looked up indoors to look after
the kids and cook dinner and get home
because that's traditional Traditions
I lived with my grandmother for four and
a half years mate yeah and all she cares
about is looking after her man and I of
course she ironed she ironed my socks my
underwear my pillowcases like she wanted
to look after a man by ironing and
cooking and cleaning I don't agree with
everything
she was tradition that's what the women
back in the day would love to do and
that's almost what that was like their
mentalities I don't want that I want my
girl to be out there starting her own
business and being a being XYZ being
and gas her up she should have her own
confidence and look after herself and
come home to me and be like [ __ ] you
know he never guess what I did today
I'll smash this yes that's what I want
but when it comes to like when we
decided to have babies and have children
she looks after them babies I wouldn't
want anybody else in this world to look
after our children apart from apart from
the mother but if she wants to go back
to work or run a run a business from
home absolutely she can do that like I
don't agree with them traditions of
staying at home and being a stay-at-home
mum and all that [ __ ] you're gonna
get problems
what do you think that stay-at-home
mothers do what is your opinion of
estate on Mothers because you got them
down like slavery slaves
no no no no no no I know most
traditional Housewives yeah they've got
a side hustle today no no no no they
didn't explain to you my grandmother
died a few years ago hundred and odd
years ago she always had a side hustle
okay she's made for you she's running a
million she's running a million all the
women in my family who were Housewives
always have a side hustle
my brother is married my brother is 40.
yeah he's married yeah he's one life has
a side hustle okay she she goes to work
and she said they both share yeah so
yeah well let's not be naive in the fact
of thinking that's that that traditional
women back in the day were stay-at-home
wife let's not be no I'm trying to say
is that because you stay at home it
don't mean that I know exactly that so
I'm not denying that but what I'm saying
is you're saying about Traditional
Values and modern Traditional Values say
that an old school Woman by the
exception worst at home mums are cooked
and cleaned and look after the kids they
didn't go to work and then sign money
so you're trying to what you don't
understand is that
the women that stayed at home and cooked
and cleaned yeah right most of them did
not have a side hustle correct they did
not you're trying to tell me that all
those people back in the day they never
grew their own vegetables they never
baked their own bread for themselves for
themselves that is a side house
[Laughter]
you're serious yes you're serious she
knows something right useless you've got
to be surprised at what a side hustle is
okay Define understand what you mean
aside from this anything that what
you're going to say yeah that brings
money into the household anything that
stops money going out of the household
me personally right I I must I say I'm
not in definition I stay at home and I
bake cakes yeah I cater for parties yeah
I grow my own vegetables yeah right to
me okay but a modern definition of a
side hustle would cancel that yeah and
say that a modern definition of a side
hustle was bringing in money and so
you're having a secondary income from a
woman who stays at home you're not
talking about a modern definition I'm
telling you what tradition is exactly
your view of what tradition is
like stay at home cooking and cleaning
this no what I'm trying to say to you so
hope there's more to it than that of
course there is more to it than that
hustle so I believe in a woman that has
old school traditions in the fact how
many how many old people like their
knitted scarves and stuff like that and
for most of them most of them most of
them yeah so I love them I love a modern
woman today he's got a modern values
that wants to work hard work our own job
have our own company start our own
business become a CEO of xyze but when
it comes to having the babies and
whatnot I wouldn't want anyone else
somebody said that though I wouldn't
want anyone else in the world you're
going to want to understand
the company and have babies at work at
home yeah come on SO a traditional woman
can stay at home and work at home
because you've got traditional value the
internet the internet
[Music]
she's got her own job and she's got her
own business she might be she might be
an influencer she might have xyzes this
that influencer you're gonna get
problems
she's at home she's raising my kids I
don't want anybody else I don't want a
nanny I don't want x y z I want him to
be at home with my the woman I've chosen
to spend the rest of my life with
pleased
completely against what being a boss
[ __ ] is no it doesn't see no no he does
I'm telling you something I'm telling
you something oh listen but no because
you're gonna bang your head against
because what it is you're gonna meet
women that can give you this yeah but
you're gonna want them to submit to give
it and they're not gonna submit to what
no no because in order for her to go
back into a position where she's going
to be a housewife and what you want she
has to happen to your housewife because
bro you wanted to look up how do you
want to be a CEO flying out I wouldn't
get a woman or I said that earlier you
asked me aren't you what if I think I
wouldn't get a Woman Who Wasn't maternal
no just because she runs her own
business
but what I'm trying to say to you is
yeah you're making the description that
women make for the type of man they want
because they want a man to go out there
to earn to be a high flight of it yeah
all you really needed for you to say was
you know what I want my wife to be loyal
maternal give me peace whether do
whatever I stand yeah but then if you
want to say that to me it sounded like
you were describing your perfect man
yeah I was like what that's what we're
missing
in a minute hang on wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait when you hear women talking
about what they what they're out for man
to have he described the alpha man stop
the man okay what he described them no
just by going what you said why do you
want a woman who's just constantly
relying on you
said that no one said that nobody said
that why am I describing enough because
you do an extreme you do an extreme
right if it's not if it's a woman can
have modern values but traditional but
work on a woman stay at home wait wait
hold on a second why can't a woman like
um like what your nan did for example
yeah and she loved to do that why do you
attach it to the fact that she was a
slave or she didn't want to do it I
didn't say that no no no no but what do
you say when you talk about oh yeah I
don't wanna I don't want a woman to
that's gonna have to stay at home you
made it sound like so bad derogatory but
there's so many times
no women can't you keep missing the fact
women can do what they want but what do
you want do you want a boss [ __ ] that's
gonna run a CEO Company which is going
to take about 20 hours a day do you know
how much noise
because the reality in life life is not
you have to make life life is about
choices and trade us right we cannot
have everything that we want and anyone
that's won the business knows that this
is not 12 hours a day it's actually
about 18 20 sometimes and when you've
got a woman that's running the CEO
Company she's not gonna be at home
chilling do you know what it is so if
you want a woman to do that at the same
time you better sit at home with the
kids
obviously Back in the Day Men could
afford to just look after their women
and look after everything but obviously
things have changed it's a lot more
expensive and men nowadays they want
that but can you really afford that
lifestyle to look after the woman look
after everything and really and you know
what I mean and the woman just stay at
home and do nothing how much is a
submission cost how
wait a minute she just said that
for an order for a woman to stay at home
and do all these things a man in the old
days
how about what you fail to realize is
that
no matter how much money a man brings in
a real woman can manage it yeah correct
no because back in the day and it's not
for the fact that well it's not for the
fact that bills these day and ages is
just different right so makeup bills and
eyelash bills and fingernail bills
so how much is the money to earn you
know that's depending on the women some
women don't care so you've got earn 30
grand a year or you can earn 300. no but
what we're trying to say is that she
must know that in order to stay home
like the lady
would she be willing to stay home if her
man uh 20 000 pounds a year
exactly
exactly and that's what he's saying how
much would it take you to stay at home
stay at home and take care of yourself
how much would it take you can't answer
that question well you can Instagram
[Music]
very expensive
okay Brittany for the life that you live
in now yeah for you to stay at home for
you to have a child no it's not a stupid
it's a very because you guys said we're
talking about men oh we're talking about
men's I was like okay cool in order for
you to feel comfortable and
fundamentally what do you need how much
money I don't it's like it's not a trick
question it just generally it could be
100. let's be real I love going on loads
of holidays that's when I pay for myself
so then is he going to be paying for no
that's what we're saying yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes so then you can't really
put a figure
this week what does it may want to go
more like no but do you go to buy the
sweet dreams
in these places
you want to have kids you want to smoke
a house and you do the holidays that me
and you do exactly think about it and
remember your financing too so why can't
you say 100 so why can't you just say
150. I just I obviously just why I can't
even say it 150 Grand I need my man to
earn 150 Grand it's simple yeah cool
done
150 Grand he cannot sustain your
lifestyle it's simple so any man that's
trying to come out there and that's fine
if he can't but then I need to go to
work I'm working as well yeah
yeah yeah yeah my point is yeah is that
in today's day and age I feel as though
I think my grandmother who I lived with
I've spent my whole life with yeah she
raised me in that I know that the old
school women back in those days they
were to look stay at home look up they
weren't Breadwinners yeah
majority of the time they want to look
after the babies cook clean this sat in
the other bar that's it yeah today's day
and age that's it yeah but for the most
part it was yeah
for the most part as a woman I know
there's more to it that's it but go
ahead that's it but what I'm trying to
say is in today's day and age women
don't want that women want to women want
to be independent want to earn their own
money they want to look after themselves
not having to think about I have to rely
on a man so I think guessing you'll go
up to go and do that sort of stuff he's
[ __ ] top priority no no yeah and but
but when it comes Amsterdam raising a
family doesn't mean she can't run a
company from working at home living I'll
do my best to be at home and look after
them kids as well as much as possible
but I wouldn't want it when the woman
has a kid let her take a year out and
raise that baby that's the most
important year of the life I want to be
there for six months if I could to take
to take time off work to be there and
raise my kid and my wife but like I
wouldn't want anybody else raising that
kid that's so great the way you're
seeing it I can't wait for your CEOs
I'm just gonna
have these kids and work from at home
with the children I hope I'll be there
as much as I can though invite me to the
wedding you can sound like this and use
the car and put a plate you're winning
and young lady as we're winding up
[Music]
I know you're still 50 50. I just want
to know traditional modern is your man
traditional is he modern like you and
have you learned anything about
traditional based and modern women
the thing is I don't know you tell me
auntie because I feel as if myself that
I'm I am half traditional and half
modern I have modern value I'm a modern
woman I'm only 23. it's 20 22 like I am
a modern woman but then I still have a
lot of Traditional Values that I know
that my
man values I cook for him I clean for
him I'm still very reserved I haven't
slept about he knows who I've slept with
so I still feel like I'm very
traditional but then I still feel like
I'm a modern woman because I dress what
I how I want I drink quite one I'll go
out and dance and he still trust me but
he knows that I'm uh I still have
Traditional Values so it's like I am a
traditional woman I'm modern but I have
Traditional Values have you picked up
anything from anybody on the show
men want traditional women
want traditionalist women traditionally
yeah
have some of the values of traditional
women they do no it sounds like they
want traditionalist women they want
everything like Edition
by The Virgins because they know that's
impossible and they're impossible
nowadays yeah probably in the Western
World anyways
he wants them to be a boss witch and go
to work exactly right but Mason wants a
boss [ __ ] that goes to work and so I
could still be a traditional woman that
cooks for him and cleans for him and
Laser slippers out on irons his [ __ ] and
puts his pajamas on his pillows and
Cooks his dinners but then I've still
got my own business and I own my own
money so what am I
his wife yeah and you made you become a
CEO
which you was working and still putting
that cooking and doing his slippers and
everything and working 80 hours a week
personally I still do it now yeah me and
my boyfriend we both work full time I
work for the NHS he's a football who
does that football style yeah thank you
I work for the NHS auntie and he works
as he's doing but I still as a woman
feel that I need to cook clean keep the
house we've got a dog I keep the house I
keep the dog I cook him dinners his
slippers are at the top of the stairs
but I still work and I must do work a
week uh 37 and a half hours a week how
many hours a CEO work a week I don't
know but I work good I work 12 hours
I didn't say like now now you're doing
it I was just saying if you was a CEO
like a modern woman surely you're gonna
but I'm still about a modern woman no I
work 12 hour shifts I work 60 hour week
sometimes I'm a modern woman I've done
that years ago exactly but I I work I
work my shifts my shifts are 12 hours I
get up at six in the morning I go home
at six at night I cook my man dinner his
slippers are at the top of stairs his
[ __ ] shit's ironed I am a wooden
woman traditional and in a minute is
cooking how much time does it take you
to oh I love cooking aren't you and
loving and iron how long does it take I
don't know how do I how long does it
take to cook a meal an hour an hour an
hour so I work 12 hours I come home
without the season I said
I want to cook you sit down
in your to do that all the housework the
cooking the cleaning how long how many
hours a day would you take doing that
but it's not a day though because I
can't do it every day because no but I'm
saying like on average and an hour an
hour a day an hour a day okay for
cooking and cleaning or just cooking if
you put the food now if you put it all
together yeah you know that girl yeah
put the oven on and jump in the shower
do you know what right because
I'm disabled right and women make it
sound like oh yeah I do the cooking the
cleaning not me right I got airfryer
I've got airfryer rice cooker I got slow
cooker
cookies not that hard I got I got a
washer dryer so you take it out hang a
dry you put it up I got a steamer so
that's what I'm asking and I've got
Mastiffs
that's what I'm trying to say is that
when women are saying oh I do all the
cooking I care for my mom I do the
cooking the cleaning and she disabled do
the cooking the cleaning and do her
clothes out and do all that and do a
medication and everything so
it's not that hard being a housewife
that is why nowadays traditional is
woman laugh when people say that because
if I say to my boyfriend ah I was
working so hard I'd done all the washing
washing today he said you're taking the
piss you don't wash you've got a washing
machine in the dryer you know because
back in the day back in the day it was
washing so if I go and say to him now oh
I've cooked all this meal for
and I've done this and I've done that
he'd be like
yeah
in a minute why are you cooking for an
hour what are you cooking that you're
cooking for today
fresh ingredients
washing garlic chopping an onion
chopping up parsley getting fresh fresh
washing your meat soaking your
vegetables
my dad's Jamaican do you think I'm not
washing about me and soaking my
vegetables my dad's a chef so I know how
much it goes into cooking right it's not
as simple right acting like I've not
been at work for 12 hours and dealt with
dead bodies and Trauma and [ __ ] and then
hahaha
do you know something about it I thought
that I was going to go for one show
without hearing words
have you have you I got your mum on the
phone and told her how to give CPR to a
two year old baby I got you no I've
actually no I've been the woman that's
done it have you I've been the woman
that's done it okay right at the end of
the
day
man complaining about the smell
do you know what I mean you chose that
career you chose that career so as far
as I'm concerned yeah I'm gonna be
I'm gonna stay at home because I'm gonna
[ __ ] help the NHS I'm staying at home
I'm cooking I'm cleaning I'm [ __ ]
sweeping don't give me a career because
I'm a traditional woman that don't do
[ __ ] that is that's it what do you mean
traditional women don't do [ __ ] don't
tell me you know what do they do that's
what I'm trying to say how could they
not they work or do they know tell me
what do I do if I'm a traditional woman
I want problems always you know some
people I do Auntie a traditional woman
and you know what the one thing that
they keep on saying don't talk over
people and then you get listen I ask
somebody come on to the other day and
call me broth that's just as bad as you
do you know I know it's like
I just stay at home all the time
all because I said it's not so hard it's
not so hard nowadays you've got all the
gadgets there your dad's a chef I love
cooking you know what I mean but if you
go and you look at my Tick Tock you will
see it's not that hard when you know
what you're doing it's not that hard all
you need and you're talking about
crushing garlic come on you got a sharp
knife
listen right don't tell me about the
prep because I've done the prep with
pearl Pearl right pearl ain't got no
Jamaican relatives and pearl had a
housewarming
and she I hope she puts up the video
Pearl down the prep the washing the
chicken the rice and peas they actually
made the coleslaw she made everything
cut the vowels it was all done put 50
people wow no what I'm trying to say is
that that is a white girl who's learning
from scratch that didn't know how to do
it
so for a couple of hours with me showing
them how to do it and she was doing that
regular or if it was in her culture or
she had Jamaican in it it wouldn't be a
problem so as far as I'm concerned
I haven't I'm having it that all this
cooking and cleaning and whatever
because obviously years ago they did
that but like you said they didn't have
a normal job working how many hours they
didn't have all the mod cons to do it
but then what she's saying is doing both
is a lot in itself
to manage your time one thing I will say
as well yeah it's just like like
obviously I just think
foreign
like when you meet these women like they
generally want to feed you they're
worried about you because anyone that's
ever been in a man's house or man's life
you actually realize we don't eat that
well like you know like like if you're
actually uh no the reason I say that is
all our spoilers do no I can I can cook
I cook well but when you run your own
business or when you're as active as I
am trust me you're gonna miss things
like you haven't got time to Chef up and
do things you haven't I don't agree
all right listen okay trust me when you
okay I have a very busy active life I
eat but as a man I can cook but as a man
you've only got certain hours in the day
meal prep yeah meal prep okay cool but
I'm giving an example right yeah it's a
bad example bro no because I can't give
you an example because okay
like the whole reason that you have
um cleaners and cooks and people and you
order things out certain times because
of time I think that's laziness not
laziness if in an hour if an hour or two
if I can make a certain amount of money
in an hour or two I'm gonna use those
two hours to make a certain amount of
money now with those with the money I've
made now I can pay for cleaner I can pay
for a chef at some point I would have a
partner that would know that babe oh my
gosh you're putting all this work I see
what you doing have you eating and she'd
be like you know what I've made this for
you or if you're in the house I'm gonna
cut this for you because having a party
when they call it your bet your other
half or your better half is because
they're supposed to complete you there's
things that being when you're a man that
a woman's gonna come and finish and help
your life and it's things that you're
gonna do to her life that you're gonna
finish so we don't believe in that what
men and women are supposed to be their
others and complete you know so what's
the point of having someone then
the way I describe your life yeah when
it comes to your life your life is a
meal and your life should already be
pretty your meal should already be
pretty good I enjoy everything that's on
that meal I've got a pretty good life
I've got a very good friendship good
family good social life I'm very very
active I'm up very very early I'm
training with the boys I'm running
active on the weekends we go on holidays
my meal is [ __ ] good
if a woman's gonna come into that life
and she's going to be permanent she has
to add something she needs to add a
condiment to that she needs to be really
good like if you're gonna have a lamb
roast you need to have a bit of mint
sauce she might be that mint sauce but
without that mint sauce my meal's
already [ __ ] good mate so whoever you
come and you add a condiment to it and
it adds it fantastic meal that's going
to add even more better to it but if
that lamp if that mint sauce ain't there
my lamb roast is already still banging
whether you're there or not oh no I
don't believe it I'll be honestly I'll
be honest with you I'm doing well by
myself but with a woman I'll do even
better because she's going to inspire me
okay yeah you should Inspire yourself
well she's not there and I'm doing I'm
successful anyway but once she's there
she gives me a charge you know I've got
I've got a legacy now I got I got
someone that's telling me baby go out
there actually making me proud you know
what it feels like I know you know what
it feels like right then why why get a
woman
like why but that's what I'm saying 3.5
for what I'm saying is that that woman
comes in she's incredible but but my
life's really good it's not saying that
she ain't gonna enhance them well that's
not incredible he didn't say it his life
wasn't good he was just okay no no my
life is amazing but look listen my life
is good right yeah it's good for him
but he hasn't got a problem eating
takeaway because he's working and
earning money but she will come along
and she would say all right then you're
working earlier about a woman has a home
she a woman makes a house at home yeah I
agree but well that's good CEO that's
working eight years a week
you can make it home yeah okay trust me
she could pay for someone else to make
it at home but I don't think she can
physically be there herself to make it
because she
you should be really complete in your
life and that you're like if someone
comes into your heart into your life you
make that life between you amazing you
shouldn't rely on somebody else to make
your life better or give you a kick up
the ass in the morning to get yourself
to go what's the point of having
somebody in your life if they're going
to make your life better I'm happy my
man makes me happier I'm better and I'm
better I'm more better without him with
him he just makes my life complete my
life I'm happy on my own I've got a full
life on my own it's just that he just
adds the icing on the cake I get that I
get that but without him you still have
a good life yeah but why am I gonna have
a good life when I can have one I agree
I agree I agree and that's what he's
saying he's got a good life but when
you've got someone there and you're
working together and you're supporting
each other it just makes it that much
better and it takes some of the stress
off of you correct I agree correct right
ladies young lady
um what was the question again I forgot
modern traditional
um which is the way to go has anything
changed your mind to just know but I'm
still modern obviously I go out and you
know but just having those values and
just respecting your partner and just
knowing you know I've got a man I need
to kind of like think of him in the
background so if you look picked up
anything from anyone here no because I
kind of thought that at the beginning so
I'll go with what I said right just
being considerate okay well I'm gonna
say good night oh I need to say hello to
Matt butcher thanks for your support
and um didn't read out yeah I think we'd
had the super chats because
I know I said I was identifying as Pearl
but I haven't got my laptop with me so
I'm really sorry and I don't want to be
rude going on my phone so
Pearl's over and out and don't forget to
subscribe and let me know what you think
and I will be
chatting in the chat so good night over
and out good night thank you